bonsoir croyez vous que ce soit
seulement avec les mots union et liste
d'union que nous attirerons demain les
jeunes les femmes et les verts je pense
qu'ils attendent de nous un
renouvellement
c'est pour cela que je milite avec
d'autres d'ailleurs avec les rénovateurs
du rpr de façon à entraîner toute
l'opposition sur une voie constructive
rénové et recentré alors monsieur juppé
ces trois petites phrases prononcées à
l'heure de vérité du 20 mars dernier par
monsieur pierre méhaignerie ont
déclenché dans vos rangs la fronde que
vous savez les 32 rénovateur de
l'opposition demandent aujourd'hui que
monsieur giscard d'estaing s'effacer
qu'il renonce à conduire la liste rpr
udf aux prochaines élections européennes
le conseil national du rpr rappelons le
qui s'est réuni samedi à paris et dont
vous êtes le secrétaire général ne veut
rien entendre c'est donc l'impasse
c'est dire si l'épisode qui va se jouer
ce soir en direct devant les français
est attendue grâce à l'heure de vérité
on va peut-être enfin savoir où on en
est comme le fait dire jacques faisant
aussi personnage de son dessin du figaro
de ce matin à l'origine de la crise
actuelle je le rappelle l'europe qui va
nous contraindre à moderniser nos
pratiques politiques et nos
comportements
faut-il par exemple continué d'envoyer à
l'assemblée européenne les dirigeants
qui contrôlent le jeu politique français
depuis plusieurs décennies
faut-il que les élus du 18 juin prochain
résident à strasbourg et qu'ils
renoncent à leurs mandats nationaux et
qu'elle est dans le nouveau paysage
européen
l'avenir des grands partis hiérarchisé
et historiques comme le vôtre alors au
delà des tensions entre générations
c'est essentiellement de cela de la
modernisation en profondeur de la vie
politique française que nous allons
parler ce soir avec alain duhamel avec
josette alia du nouvel observateur et
avec albert du roy
sans oublier bien sûr de parler de
l'europe elle-même détonateur de la
crise actuelle
vous me direz comment le rpr voit ce
nouvel espace économique politique et
culturel et quel rôle la france devrait
selon lui
jouer alors avant avant tout nous allons
commencer par une première question
comme d'habitude des téléspectateurs que
va vous poser jean-louis le scène avoue
svp alain juppé bonsoir depuis 20h le
standard de svp et passablement occupés
et autant vous dire tout de suite que ce
sont les contestataires les rénovateurs
où les novateurs du rpr qui embouteille
le standard autant vous dire qu'on vous
interroge un peu sur la corse mais très
peu un peu sur le liban mais très peu un
peu sur l'europe mais très peu ce qui
provoque les questions vous en doutez
c'est d'abord la querelle au sein de la
droite
avec cette première question que je vous
pose maintenant pourquoi est il si
important de faire des listes d'union de
l'opposition au lieu de laisser les
partis aller à la bataille sous leur
propre drapeau ce qui permettrait de se
rendre compte de l'importance relative
de chaque partie après tout on est à la
proportionnelle on peut se poser la
question c'est tout à fait exact
et certains se la sont posée il ya
d'ailleurs une formation politique au
sein d'une opposition qui depuis
plusieurs mois a pris position en faveur
des listes séparées c'est le centre
démocrate de monsieur pierre méhaignerie
ça n'est pas tout à fait notre analyse
et pour notre part nous pensons que si
on va tous ensemble dans ces élections
on fera un meilleur score que si on y va
séparément imaginait un petit peu le
score que pourrait obtenir une liste
dans laquelle on trouverait monsieur
giscard d'estaing madame simone veil
françois léotard pierre mehiri moi même
et tous les jeunes du rpr et de l'udf
je suis sûr que pour parler un peu
familièrement elle ferait un malheur
ah voilà pourquoi nous militons pour
l'union avec quelque chose que je
voudrais tout de suite ajouté c'est que
nous sommes d'accord sur l'europe que
nous voulons construire c'était ça qu'il
fallait d'abord vérifier nous l'avons
vérifié
nous avons signé un texte en commun
alors pourquoi ne pas faire l'union bien
alors on va continuer sur ce terrain là
avec un majeur
elle pour un quart d'heure alain duhamel
monsieur juppé
bonsoir c'est exprès que vous avez parlé
à propos de pierre méhaignerie du centre
démocrate qui ce qui est une expression
qu'on utilisait il ya une dizaine
d'années j'ai voulu vieillir un peu on
ne me prêterai pas tout de suite ces
mauvaises intentions non j'ai voulu ne
pas utiliser ainsi que je sais que c'est
officiellement le cds à dire quand
hier soir vous avez regardé la
télévision et que vous avez vu des
hommes de votre âge de votre génération
et des hommes qui en tout cas en
l'occurrence se présentait comme
enraciné dans l'opposition comme vous
c'était ici même
charles millon qui le président de la
région rhône alpes c'était dominique
baudis que le maire de toulouse il ya
c'était bosson qui est l'ancien ministre
affaires européennes dans le
gouvernement qu'elle vous participiez
vous même quand vous avez tous ces
hommes qui se sont tournés vers valéry
giscard d'estaing en l'adjurant de
passer le flambeau à votre génération
pour arriver à mobiliser l'ensemble de
l'opposition est ce que vous vous rendez
vous et vous n'êtes pas senti un petit
peu de leur côté quand même je me suis
posé simplement une question pourquoi et
j'ai ensuite essayé d'y répondre
comment eh bien je vais essayer si vous
voulez très simplement d'apporter
quelques éléments de réponse
il ya une première raison qui pourrait
justifier cette offensive de nos amis
contestataires jeudi nos amis parce que
ne dramatisons pas ce sont nos amis
c'est que nous ne soyons pas d'accord
sur l'europe et que l'europe que veut
construire monsieur giscard d'estaing ou
tel autre parti de l'opposition ne soit
pas la même que celle qu'ils veulent
construire eux et j'ai constaté que ça
n'était pas le cas puisque nous avons
vous le savez vous êtes très avertis de
ces choses là semaine dernière signé un
texte commun qui est notre projet pour
l'europe et notre projet pour la france
en europe j'aimerais bien qu'on en parle
un petit peu et je vais même si vous me
le permettez en parler tout de suite
parce que plutôt que de parler au juste
un mot plutôt que par les airs up j'ai
essayé moi d'aller voir sur place
on n'est jamais mieux servi que par soi
même j'ai donc commencé il ya quelques
semaines un tour d'europe
les capitales européennes je suis allé à
bruxelles à madrid à londres à
luxembourg à la haie et je vais
continuer
et j'ai pris conscience de deux choses
en rencontrant les premiers ministres un
tas de chair monsieur felipe gonzalez
la première c'est que tout le monde ne
veut pas la même europe certains vols ce
que laurent fabius appelait joliment une
europe terrain vague
c'est à dire une sorte d' espaces des
marchandises et des capitaux qui
seraient ouvertes à la marée américano
asiatique
et puis il ya ceux qui veulent une
europe qui existe par lui-même une
europe qui défendent des valeurs
par exemple sur le liban ne fait pas
trop faut bien le dire une europe qui
sache parler d'une seule voix monsieur
gorbatchev une europe qui est un projet
éducatif une europe qui est un projet
culturel bref une europe des hommes et
bien c'est cette europe que nous voulons
aussi bien michel noir que jacques
chirac que valéry giscard d'estaing que
tous les autres dans l'opposition et là
alors il ya pas de blocage de ce côté là
alors quand les rénovateurs puisqu'il se
présente comme tel ou qu'on les appelle
comme tel quand les rénovateurs 10
s'il y avait une liste de votre
génération sirenis de votre génération
ça pourrait être la liste de toute
l'opposition et ce serait donc la liste
de l'union si c'est valéry giscard
d'estaing qui dirige la liste ça sera
forcément la mort ce de deux listes et
ça sera donc forcément la division au
sein de l'opposition puisque vous avez
réfléchi à ça qu'est ce que vous
répondez
je trouve ce raisonnement très curieux
c'est l'heure à vous êtes d'accord oui
bien sûr par exemple votre ami le sualg
a par exemple encore développé
l'argument à votre conseil samedi je
trouve ce raisonnement très curieux je
me demande pourquoi on excommunie ray
telle personnalité plutôt que tel autre
je vous ai dit que j'avais essayé de me
poser de questions la première c'était
qu'à l'europe n'ait parlé très
rapidement et la deuxième est ce que
nous pouvons faire l'union alors je les
pose et au rpr cette question et samedi
ce dieu il n'a pas refusé de bouger il
n'a pas refusé le dialogue le rpr il a
dit je suis prêt à l'union à une énorme
majorité
donc nous avons pour l'union le rpr et
puis tournant nous du côté de l'udf
puisque tentant de se marier il faut
être deux et dans l'opposition il ya le
rpr et l'udf l'udf a réfléchi à cette
question
le parti républicain de mon ami françois
léotard qui est ici représentée par al
ahmad là gérard longuet roger chinaud a
dit oui à cette solution
il représente ce n'est pas très bien les
chiffres me disant tu prêt avec ses
alliés les deux tiers de l'udf
ça fait quoi le rpr les deux tiers de
l'udf ça fait 80 % de l'opposition c'est
tellement vrai et ça ne vous a pas
échappé
on nous parle beaucoup des régions de
l'importance du fait régional y venir
glisse neuf présidents de région qui à
partir de l'opposition sur ces 19
présidents de région et elle a 18 qui
ont dénoué d'accord pour cette formule
il reste 20 % de l'opposition qui n'est
pas encore en prêt excusez-moi de
parodier un langage qui n'est pas de
politique de l'alliance dans la vie vers
l'adhésion à l'union dans la maison
commune de l'opposition et je me suis
demandé pourquoi leur choix qu'il ya
deux raisons pour aller jusqu'au bout de
ma réponse à votre question
la première raison d'abord c'est une
raison d' analyse politique
il y à un certain nombre de responsables
de l'opposition pierre méhaignerie en
tête qui ne veulent pas d'une liste
d'union ils l'ont dit depuis trois mois
là ils disent le contraire non non non
non si si ils l'ont dit non je ne savais
pas qu'ils ont raison de le dire je suis
la base le contraire monsieur duhamel
depuis le début de l'année depuis le
mois de janvier
je peux vous apporter la liste des
déclarations de pierre meyer y compris
le 5 avril dernier ya cinq jours y
compris dimanche dernier à laquelle
pierre mary dit et c'est respectable je
ne le montre pas du doigt c'est une
analyse qui qui s'explique dans laquelle
pierre meys rider pour ratisser plus
large
reprenant à vocabulaire bien connue de
tout le monde il vaut mieux de liste
c'est une première explication alors
c'est vrai qu'il a dit ensuite s'il y
avait sous certaines conditions une
liste de jeux sur wii on pourrait certes
on parle mais on va jusqu après l'arrêt
en salle jusqu'à présent mais je veux
quand même le rappeler parce qu'il ne
faut pas non plus inversez les rôles
jusqu'à présent et pendant trois mois
monsieur pierre méhaignerie un certain
nombre de ses amis centristes ont bilité
pour deux listes
alors que nous nous avons toujours
milité pour une soliste et puis une
deuxième région
là comme c'est l'heure de vérité je vais
vous dire franchement les choses c'est
qu'il ya des arrière pensées derrière
tout ça tout le monde se dit lorsqu'on
voit apparaître monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing la tête de la liste de
l'opposition ou youyous et qu'est ce qui
va se passer après mais moi je le dis
très clairement nous ne préparons pas
les élections présidentielles le choix
que nous faisons aujourd'hui ne préjuge
nullement de ce que nous faisons feront
aux présidentielles
nous préparons les européennes et aux
européennes il n'y a pas un candidat yen
à 81 alors on peut faire du
renouvellement avec les plus tôt plus
que les autres quand même c'est celui
qui est tête de liste
bien sûr et pourquoi nous prévoyons nous
d'avoir monsieur giscard d'estaing comme
tête de liste alors qu'il faut quand
même y réfléchir on va en venir je veux
rien quoi dire viennent on nous a promis
on vous fait confiance votre
donc le choix à votre dans votre esprit
il est maintenant totalement irrévocable
il y aura une liste udf rpr telle
qu'elle a été votée par la majorité de
votre conseil samedi est telle qu'elle
sera soumis au vote de l'udf jeudi c'est
le rer a dit nous voulons l'union nous
voulons l'union avec l'udf et nous
prenons la tête de liste de l'udf
nous allons voir ce que va dire l'udf le
13 avril tout donne à penser je ne suis
pas devin
l'udf dira nous voulons le président de
l'udf comme tête de liste
et à ce moment là nous ne jetterons pas
d'interdît ou d'excommunication nous
disons simplement aux autres venaient
vous ne jetterai pas d'excommunication
mais si certains ne sont pas satisfait
par cette solution et envisage tout en
proclamant qu'ils appartiennent à
l'opposition formée une autre liste
qu'est ce que vous faites vous les
exclus et ou simplement vous les 7
monestier gentiment je ne serai jamais
le secrétaire-général de l'exclusion et
je suis le dernier à qui on veut faire
ce reproche
souvenez vous quand je suis arrivé à ce
poste il y a huit ou neuf mois
maintenant le rpr était dans une
situation pas très facile nous sortions
des présidentielles et des législatives
ça n'avait pas été une grande période
pour nous alors que maintenant c'est
l'enthousiasmé non mais je voudrais
rappeler ce qui a été fait depuis
rappelé ce qui a été fait tout le monde
disait au mois d'août le rpr règles ati
n'a pas éclaté
j'ai instauré le débat au sein du rpr et
nous allons nous avons même fait samedi
dernier je crois que vos amis
journalistes ont été un peu bluffé si
vous me permettez l'expression
parce que nous avons fait nous avons
fait une première c'est la première fois
que dans une formation politique
un moment je ne dirais pas grave
n'exagérons rien mais important de son
histoire
on débat devant les caméras et devant
l'ensemble des journalistes c'est ça ma
glace non c'est après la première volée
au rpr oui c'est ça la rénovation ou rpr
et prend les socialistes sont venus pour
beaucoup débat devant beaucoup de monde
passe dans les comités des rockies en
outre les espoirs à l'espace des choses
importantes
voilà ce que j'exprime ensuite sur le
front national oui j'ai fait prendre une
position par le mouvement qui a été
totalement respecté par tout le monde
là aussi je vais pousser dans le sens de
la rénovation et je pourrais poursuivre
et jamais je n'ai brandi la menace
d'exclusion contredit très loin le pré
pas et je ne le ferai pas je désire
allemand d'exclusion il ya une majorité
qui a décidé à les larges 87%
je souhaite que tout le monde évidemment
suivent la décision de la majorité et
surtout et je leur fais encore ce soir
vraiment
comme je lé fais pendant toute la
semaine dernière auprès de tous mes amis
et auprès des centristes pourquoi ne
voulez-vous pas venir avec nous nous
sommes prêts à vous accueillir l'on dit
je vais commencer
mais ce n'est pas une raison valable on
ne peut pas on ne peut pas dire nous ne
voulons pas à cause de monsieur alors
justement monsieur monsieur juppé
puisqu'on avait promis qu'on en parlait
anne valérie giscard d'estaing pour vous
qui y être gaulliste qui est le
secrétaire général du rpr et qui ne vous
est pas toujours entendus admirablement
avec valéry giscard d'estaing pour
employer une litote le fait de voir que
c'est valéry giscard d'estaing qui sera
en l'occurrence tête de liste qui sera
en l'occurrence tête de liste et qui
donc serait l'emblème du gaullisme le
porte-parole du rpr ça vous paraît pas
légèrement sur réalisme non monsieur
giscard d'estaing ne sera pas l'emblème
d'une formule cependant pas du gaullisme
de la liste de l'opposition monsieur de
l'homme elle attendait pas non je ne
sais pas je n'ai pas vocation à fables
-dans les locaux représentent l'udf
c'est assez normal puisqu'il est passé
dans l'edf donc ce qui est nouveau c'est
quand même le fait de voir valéry
giscard d'estaing qui a beaucoup été
attaqué et qui a beaucoup attaqué aussi
d'ailleurs le rpr où les ancêtres du rpr
sur l'europe qui justement fera
forcément puisqu'il est tête de liste
figure de votre symbole je vais vous
dire monsieur duhamel ça m'amuse
beaucoup ce débat j'entends parler d'un
pays
bien sûr vous savez moi je fais de la
politique de façon finalement assez
allègre si ça me rendait malheureux je
ne la ferai pas tout ça c'est
intéressant il se passe des choses ça
bougent le monde bouge la vie politique
française aussi c'est pas mal que ça
bouge jouer simplement dire que ce qui
m'amuse c'est que j'entends à longueur
de journée d'hier qu'il ne faut pas être
archaïque qu'il faut parler du monde tel
qu'il est et tel qu'il va être alors
nous remontons pas vingt ans en arrière
de grâce à ne faisons pas de la
politique simplement avec des vieilles
cires certains sont remontés matin à
revenir le conseil samedi
bien sûr ils ont dit certains bien je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas partagé ce gars là
tuez les mains partager ce point de vue
monsieur giscard d'estaing a une belle
phrase jetons la rancune à la rivière si
nous voulons faire de la vie de la ville
l'union de l'opposition c'est
merveilleux c'est quand même merveilleux
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
ce sont ces que vous êtes ce sens est
sérieux ou l'arrêter mois permettez-moi
sérieux monsieur je vous ai je dit c'est
merveilleux l'asi la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes
weeks normes s'était érodée à un bon
prix j'ai compris après l'odyssée quand
même merveilleux la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes
qu'ils nous parlent le plus de l'union
qui nous disent il faut faire l'union de
toute l'opposition viennent excommunié
untel ou untel sous prétexte qu à 20 ans
où il ya dix ans nous n'étions pas
ensemble si on en passe par là permettez
moi de vous dire qu'il ya 20 ans ou 25
ans on peut remonter à 1945 aussi la
famille centriste n'a jamais aidé le
général de gaulle je n'ai rien contre
elle
je suis prêt ce qu'elle nous rejoigne
alors de grâce laissons ce débat c'est
vraiment le passé moi j'ai 43 ans
eh bien j'aimerais parler de l'avenir
qu'est-ce que vous n'êtes pas la crainte
si comme le souhaitait jacques chirac
dans son discours c'est une bonne
référence quand même pour vous samedi si
c'était le président de l'udf de giscard
qui était tête de liste
si vous même alain juppé secrétaire
général du rpr vous étiez le numéro deux
de la liste
et si comme semblait vraiment beaucoup
le souhaitait jacques chirac ont trouvé
françois léotard président du parti
républicain en bonne position sur cette
liste
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que ça
fasse quand même un petit peu liste
d'homme d'appareil à un moment où
apparemment les français ont quand même
un certain rejet vis-à-vis des partis
politiques je vais m'expliquer sur cette
affaire des partis politiques et des
hommes d'appareil mais c'est pour ça
vous intéresse je sais ça vient ça
vierge que j'allais même les en
remercier donc je voudrais même expliqué
parce que c'est un sujet grave savez il
ya des pays où on se bat pour avoir des
partis politiques
quand je veux pas faire de parallèle à
considérer mais vous le voyez bien en ce
moment
moi je pense que des partis politiques
qui sont utiles à la démocratie alors
opposé les jeunes leaders régionaux dont
je rappelle que 18 sur 19 ont pris
position pour la solution rpr udf la
brique président de région absolument ce
que tous ne sont prêts le gamin les
présidents brèche est vraiment fait ce
sont des leaders régionaux composés les
leaders régionaux aux appareils
parisiens
c'est quelque chose d'encore que je ne
comprends pas très bien ce serait tout à
fait fondées si les responsables de
partis politiques pierre méric et de
canettes à françois léotard ou moi même
nous étions des fonctionnaires de la
politique des apparatchiks
mais je le regrette le dire excusez moi
ce léger moment dit modestie moi ma
légitimité les démocratique et
l'étonnement aussi grande que celle de
tous mes amis je suis député j'ai été
élu j'ai conduit une liste d'union aux
municipales à paris avec roger chinaud
qui est là et moi je les fais l'union
et nous avons gagné dans un
arrondissement qui a deux cent mille
personnes
c'est l'équivalent d'une grande ville et
donc ça veut dire tout simplement [ __ ]
tous devront faire la même chose
jacques chirac dans vingt
arrondissements que nous n'avons pas été
complètement incapables de nous mettre à
l'écouté des français et de leur parler
le langage qu'ils attendent
alors que je crois que ce débat est un
débat qui est à la mode qui durera
peut-être correspond à mes manches et
les français quand même à quelque chose
je crois qu'il ne faut pas se tromper de
4 les français raison mais vous êtes
d'accord une fonction de voir beaucoup
de signes en ce moment sur mer le réseau
en question qui se pose que je veux dire
c'est qu'il faut le prendre peut-être
d'une autre manière
ne me faites pas dire que tout va très
bien que les partis politiques sont ce
qu'ils sont et qu'il faut pas les
changer je suis le dernier l'a aussi
pouvoir dire il faut les changer
vraiment fonder mme en changeant les
hommes ah mais oui partout c'est
nécessaire européenne et nous avons nous
avons commencé au municipal qui a donné
à michel noir l'investiture du rpr qu'il
réclamait savoir je peux arriver je peux
vous le dire c'est moi et il a demandé
il l'a demandé l'investiture du rpr
michel lory dans les réseaux ne la
reprise ou pas du tout c'est moi qui la
lui ai donné s'il était là peut-être
qu'un jour il ya l'occasion de dialoguer
dans leur ensemble ensemble moi je suis
prêt à dialoguer avec lui quand il
voudra il le dire elle l'a déjà dit
publie le reconnaît bien sûr oui enfin
c'est moins sûr qu'il le reconnaît très
doux ce poste non je veux dire qui êtes
d'accord avec moi que au départ il
n'avait pas l'investiture officielle de
jacques chirac au départ bien sûr que
s'il a eu dès le 5 que la creuse l'ont
pas refaire l'histoire
là aussi c'est le passé ont joué des et
simplement qu'il faut renouveler les
partis politiques renouveler les hommes
et renouveler les idées
alors vous me dites renouveler les
hommes et vous avez à nouveau en tête
monsieur giscard dessert jour et toi me
revenir parce qu'on n'y est pas encore
revenu j'ai dit que la liste européenne
c'était 80 une personne et nous allons y
mettre des candidates et des candidats
qui d'abord soient jeunes pour beaucoup
d'entre eux mais y aura aussi des gens
d'expérience qui seront ensuite motivée
par l'europe qui s'y intéressent et
enfin qu'il soit disponible qui rompt
san occupé à strasbourg pourquoi ce
brive et à la tête de cette liste qui
sera ainsi composé d'un homme qui a été
président de la république française qui
sait de quoi il parle quand il parle de
l'europe et qui au parlement de
strasbourg aura naturellement une presse
d'un prestige notoriété un rôle à jouer
que je n'aurais pas moi et qu'aucun de
mes amis n'auraient alors il faut pas se
tromper d'élection je crois que pour les
élections
celle-là c'est un atout monsieur je vais
vous venez de dire à l'instant que sur
la liste il faudrait des hommes et des
femmes qu'ils soient motivés qu'ils
soient prêts à s'occuper de l'europe et
à y consacrer l'essentiel de leurs
efforts
vous vous même vous êtes le numéro 2
potentiel de cette liste et
si vous vous présentez vous serez élu en
deuxième place vous comment est ce que
vous ferez vous irez vous installer à
strasbourg où vous au plus près d'eux du
parlement européen en plus du rpr en
même temps que de l'assemblée nationale
comment j'étais un peu surpris quand je
ne sais plus qui a dit tout à l'heure
qu'il fallait que les députés européens
résidant à strasbourg je dois vous dire
que les marocains qui réveille de sa
supposée poser la question c'était pas
la question
vous me demandez est ce que vous allez
me réinstaller est qu'est ce qu'ils
allaient faire pendant des jours elles
ont montré clairement dessus monsieur
duhamel
il y à une loi sur les cumuls en france
oui je suis déjà député j'ai tout à
l'heure et je suis également adjoint au
maire de maire de paris ab-so-lu-ment
donc si je suis élu es et éco et
conseiller général
la force des choses oui mais à penly
c'est la même chose devant l'omc si vous
êtes vraiment la plus non dans le bilan
s'est confondue donc si vous êtes élu
ben je vais au bout de ma réponse si je
suis élue au parlement de strasbourg jeu
sera bien choisir et j'irai
naturellement à strasbourg
je ne vois pas comment après ce que j'ai
dit je pourrais faire autrement tant que
vous démissionniez quelle fonction
écoutez je choisirai le moment venu
voulait pas nous le dire là c'est
l'heure de vérité
oui mais ça mérite réflexion ce que ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que je suis
profondément attaché à mon
arrondissement le xviiie arrondissement
que j'anime avec roger chinaud et un
certain nombre de gens qui sont ici dans
mon équipe donc qui gêneraient de vos
fonctions d'adjoint au maire de paris
anne ont justement pas ah bon je vais y
réfléchir je vous le répète c'est un
point qui sera tranché après les
élections mais je jouerai le jeu
jusqu'au bout ça me paraît tout à fait
normal alors pour reprendre une question
plus générale cette fois ci est ce que
vous n'avez pas le sentiment si comme
apparemment ça a l'air de se dessiner
il ya deux listes au sein de
l'opposition et si comme toujours quand
il ya deux listes il ya forcément des
mots désagréables qui sont échangées
forcément peut-être même dans votre des
réflexions déplaisante et est ce que
vous n'avez pas l'impression que les
français qui ont voté pour vous pour
l'opposition sens large rond un peu le
sentiment que nous faut être plus pour
l'opposition il ya une occasion de
rénovation qui sera passé comme ça qu'on
n'aura pas saisi tout à fait mais ça
j'en suis convaincu vous avez lu
je n'en doute pas la motion que nous
avons adoptée sanaa oui que disons-nous
je sais qu'aux élites aux log averti
qu'avant nous dit dans cette motion nous
voulons l'union et nous appelons tous
ceux qui ne sont pas encore avec nous à
nous rejoindre et je recommence ce soir
puisque j'ai la chance d'être sur le
plateau de l'heure de vérité c'est à
notre portée
c'est à portée de main nous avons déjà
fait 80 % du chemin que nos amis money
sup arrivée voyez je veux aller jusqu'au
bout de l'heure de vérité j'ai essayé la
semaine dernière j'ai vu longuement
pierre meillerie françois léotard
d'autres amis j'ai essayé d'arriver à ce
résultat
pour différentes raisons que j'ai exposé
je n'y suis pas arrivé si michel noir et
les autres n'y arrive je dirais chapeau
et je le souhaite je leur demande donc
de ramener au bercail de l'opposition
dans cette liste commune simone veil si
elle le souhaite et tous ceux qui
voudront bien siéger
je vais commencer à partir de demain
avec la commission d'investiture du rpr
à préparer la liste de nos candidats eh
bien je dis ici ce soir que sur cette
liste jusqu'au dernier moment
jusqu'au dépôt des listes je garderai
une place pour nos contestataires ils
pourront venir siéger
jusqu'au dernier moment s'ils se
décident une seule doit pas faire mieux
des places 12 % est ce que quand on voit
la manière dont les choses se passent
et est ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui ce
que vous vous sentez vraiment partisan
d' essayer de constituer après les
élections européennes
une grande confédération ou une
organisation nouvelle avec les
différentes composantes de l'opposition
ou pas tout à fait j'en suis toujours
convaincu j'ai fait il ya quelques temps
excusez moi de me citer c'était dans le
journal le monde un papier dans lequel
je disais pour l'opposition il y avait
la voix courte élève la voix langues
la voix courte c'est quoi c'est qu'on se
met tous ensemble et il n'y a aucune
raison de ne pas être ensemble
bernard bosson vous l'avez signalé tout
à l'heure a été ministre de jacques
chirac
c'est donc bien que pendant deux ans il
était d'accord avec la politique que
nous menons toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour que nous retrouvions tous
et si nous arrivons à faire cette liste
d'union ce n'est pas encore un possible
nous prendrons ensuite des initiatives
pour constituer une vaste confédération
l'opposition si ça n'est pas possible ça
sera la voile ronde de c'est à dire
qu'il faudra faire une confédération
avec ceux qui nous ont rejoints sur
cette liste et et à ceux comme par
exemple charles pasque ok quelqu'un pour
qui faisait beaucoup de considération et
qui était également au gouvernement
chirac avec vous quand des gens comme
jambes comme charles pasqua vous dise
oui mais face à ces une confédération
une fusion quelle que soit la formule
c'est la dissolution du gaullisme il
faut au contraire revenir aux sources
réaffirmait qu on ait des gaullistes
donc par nature qu'on est différent des
autres composantes de l'opposition
s'il le dit c'est vrai quand même des
problèmes là et quand j'entends michel
noir baudis et quelques autres dire il
n'y a plus aucune différence entre nous
je crois qu'on va encore un peu loin là
je crois qu'il faut une confédération
qu'est ce que c'est une confédération
c'est un ensemble qui discutent qui
travaillent en commun mais où chacun
peut garder sa personnalité
je crois que c'est dans cette voie qu'il
faut naylor comme justement on a
dernière question des questions comme
justement on en a un exemple de
confédération c'est l'udf ainsi une
confédération
chaque partie il ya sa place chacun
comme vous venez de le dire à sa
personnalité on discute ce que vous
trouvez que ça marche bien l'udf coûteux
ce n'est pas moins de porter de jugement
c'est à l'udf vous êtes en france et en
prospection je vais vous dire au risque
de vous surprendre ça dure depuis dix
ans ça a duré dix ans et ça pas si mal
tenu le choc donc aucun mal à réellement
mais des moments au moment au modèle
peut toujours progresser dans la vie
naturellement le moment des élections
municipales quand nous avons négocié les
investitures
je me suis aperçu que l'udf ça existe et
que ça tenait bon que nous avions en
face des partenaires décidé alors ne
répétons pas l'histoire faisons preuve
d'imagination et je crois que c'est une
structure confédérale soyons concrets
sont prêtes à peut-être un petit peu
abscons pour les téléspectateurs mais
nous avons proposé qu'à l'assemblée
nationale il ya un intergroupe et nous
avons proposé que l'on fasse un bureau
politique commun de l'opposition
je suis convaincu en tout cas décidés à
faire en sorte que le 19 juin
eh bien nous poursuivions dans ce sens
on va pas s'arrêter le 18 juin au 19
juin
quelle qu'ait été la configuration dans
laquelle nous ayons jamais eu ça c'est
vraiment facile de répondre par oui ou
par non c'est vraiment le dernier mot
toujours se méfier de ces questions
objet objectivement quand vous regarder
le chemin parcouru depuis l'année
dernière
depuis l'élection présidentielle que
vous voyez où vous êtes aujourd'hui vous
c'est à dire l'opposition modérée
l'opposition d'alternance
est ce que vous trouvez vous allez mieux
ça cafouille un peu je disais le
contraire vous ne me croiriez pas mais
il ya des moments où il faut une bonne
purge et ensuite sa ferme
et de repartir en meilleure santé je
suis optimiste bien merci alain duhamel
alors pendant qu'alain duhamel vous
interroger la sofres a posé comme
question la première sur le 81e hommes
de votre liste là comme tête de liste de
l'union de l'opposition préféreriez vous
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing car il
a la dimension européenne 56% une
personnalité comme michel noir car il
faut avant tout rénové l'opposition de
30% ses deux clients 14 commentaires
je n'ai pas besoin de commenter c'est ce
que j'ai essayé d'expliquer à l'instant
et je crois que c'est le bon sens bien
sûr le débat au sein du rpr
le débat de ces derniers jours au sein
du rpr vous êtes il parut réellement
démocratique alors là vous allez voir
les avis sont très partagés
oui 33 non 34 sans opinion 33 ça va dans
le bon sens parce qu'on aurait posé la
question il ya six mois je crois qu'on
aurait eu beaucoup plus de noms qu'il ya
aujourd'hui via svp d'autres questions
jean louis de seine mais monsieur juppé
le 3 avril vous avez dit que l'argent
que donne l'état la corse va aux
compagnies navigation aérienne d'où
tenez-vous ces informations excusez moi
de vous rappeler sur le scène que j'ai
été ministre du budget et que donc j'ai
quelques souvenirs
l'état dépense 750 millions de francs au
type de ce qu'on appelle la continuité
territoriale c'est à dire pour essayer
de faire en sorte par un peu paradoxal
que la corse ne soit plus vraiment une
île cet argent va pour l'essentiel à des
compagnies de navigation maritime et
pour une petite part une centaine de
millions à des compagnies de navigation
aérienne et c'est que j'ai dit c'est que
je ne suis pas sûr que cet argent soit
bien utiliser il suffit de prendre un
billet d'avion pour aller à ajaccio à
bastia pour s'en rendre compte il faut
sans doute changer les méthodes
autre question oui une autre question
qui concerne le xviiie arrondissement
qu'allez vous faire dans
l'arrondissement question en ce qui
concerne les demandes d'appartements
c'est un problème qui ne se pose pas
dans le xviiie il se pose en particulier
dans 18e nous allons construire et nous
avons sur ce point toute une série de
projets roger chinaud qui est qui est là
et qui est maire du xviiie
arrondissement les connaît bien
je ne vais pas les énumérer ici car tout
le monde ne connaît pas le xviiie
arrondissement
et puis nous allons rénover le
patrimoine existant c'est
l'arrondissement où il ya beaucoup d'
hlm nous sommes en train d'y mettre le
confort des ascenseurs des pièces des
pièces d'eau etc
nous avons un énorme effort à faire
c'est vrai c'est un problème douloureux
et nos habits du xviiie arrondissement
savent bien que nous y consacrons de
toutes nos forces en leur disant la
vérité et en leur disant que ce ne sera
malheureusement pas régler du jour au
lendemain jean-louis revenons aux
européennes au cours des élections
n'avez vous pas peur de voir l'électorat
de droite se dévier vers un électorat
socialiste ou front national ou même
vers je crois que tout va dépendre
maintenant de notre force de persuasion
il faut que nous expliquions l'europe
que nous voulons jamais dit un mot tout
à l'heure j'espère qu'on y reviendra
il faut convaincre c'est ça une campagne
électorale nous y mettrons tous les
jeunes les moins jeunes
et là encore je reviens sur un point que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure chacun sait
bien que monsieur giscard d'estaing sur
ce point de vue d'abord une très grande
compétence en même temps un très grand
talent pédagogique il a d'ailleurs
annoncé il va là parler cet après midi
qu'ils prendraient une initiative dans
les prochains jours qui sera une
initiative pour expliquer l'initiative
de communication sur l'europe
précisément bien josette alia du nouvel
observateur pour un quart d'heure
ces coupes et bonsoir sommes peut-être
changer un peu de sujet parce que je oui
vous êtes et quatre mystérieux au fond
en politique
vous êtes à des hommes politiques que je
crois qu'on ne connaît pas très bien où
peu de sucre auprès des moins bien je
sais pas pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes
timide
ils sont au top sans doute ap château
avec les femmes alors je vais en
profiter
est-ce que vous cultivez assez votre
look un peu ou beaucoup ou vraiment pas
assez sans doute pas assez puisqu'on ne
connaît pas et ainsi vous appelle vous
permet de vous pose quelques petites
questions très course pourrait répondre
très rapidement un questionnaire ultra
connus mais je crois que ça vous
permettra d'éclairer un peu votre
personnalité quel est votre principal
défaut j'ai du mal à choisir je crois
que j'en ai plusieurs
je suis un peu impatient si vous ne ça
fait déjà très bien calé dès le premier
mal à choisir à c'est un défaut serait
politique aussi non je crois que j'ai
donné l'exemple depuis plusieurs années
d'une certaine constance dans les
convictions
on me reproche parfois dire quel est
votre rêve de bonheur la musique et je
suis absolument incapable de pratiquer
le moins d'instruments c'est un des
grands regrets dans la vie oui et dans
la musique qu'il va être compositeur
préféré dans l'encart deuxième exemple
ne sait pas choisir j'aime beaucoup de
sortes de musiques
je crois quand même que si je partais
sur l'île déserte que vous êtes en train
de construire
j'amènerai sans doute la passion selon
saint matthieu de jean sébastien bach
c'est la première chose qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est non ce paisible paisible
et qui la faute si vous inspire de plus
d'indulgence
je ne sais pas je peux vous dire celle
qui m'inspire le moins c'est la sottise
est mais elle du jazz aux critiques sur
la sottise non non au pire mais pour le
reste aussi très largement trail travers
de l'enjeu quelle est la qualité vous
préférez je suis une femme à doha
là vous allez vous faire c'est que son
pliage malaisie allez-y carrément le
regard sombre un regard si kelly c line
up ça n'est pas une qualité là je crois
que d'humanité
c'est une qualité faudra expliquer ça
qu'elle est plus grand malheur qui
pourrait vous arriver je dois perdre à
naître j'aime bien sûr sit-in flers
discussion et à côté on m'a posé la
question pendant la campagne des
municipales et il ya eu des réponses
enfants ne m'a pas posé avant la pause
et pendant la campagne une réponse d'un
de mes amis qui a dit une rose et une
réponse donne mes adversaires je pense
qu il ya d une ortie pas si c'est une
fleur une plante dans les deux cas il ya
des oui oui tout perdre enfin il se peut
pourriez quitter un politique a sûrement
j'ai eu plusieurs fois la tentation en
ce moment ah non pas du tout
rationnement pas du tout par le passé ça
peut revenir demain ok pourquoi ça vous
n'êtes pas tellement dans le passé dans
un passé récent les deux ou trois ans
j'avais envie de faire autre chose et
moi je supprime panique puisque vous
vous demandez parler un peu à coeur
ouvert alors je vais le faire voyez
c'est difficile ça ne vient que
maintenant moi ce qui me panique c'est
de cette passé 30 ans 40 ans 50 ans de
ma vie dans des fonctions électives je
vois je me critiquer personne mais un
certain nombre d'élus qui à 75 ans 80
ans du mal à décrocher l'or ça c'est
pour moi la terreur absolue je ne le
cache pas n'importe quoi alors ils
feraient quoi vous ce que vous savez
faire vous savez pas vous avez chanté
savez jardiner bricoler vous avez été
président mode je ne sais rien faire et
ce que ça prend un peu tout faire je ne
sais pas
dit qu'on n'est pas condamné faire
carrière on pouvait s que c'est pas
justement un des vices de la politique
c'est vrai c'est tout à fait vrai alors
certains choisissent j'ai eu beaucoup de
sympathie et d'admiration je dois dire
purdom comme jacques douffiagues il a
une déception politique et puis les
parties je trouve que ça ça du panache
il faut du courage va falloir savoir
vous retenir autrement vous risquez de
partir comme ça très bien et vous avez
fait normale sup et puis vous avez fait
l'ena alors qu'est-ce que vous avez
préféré des deux ans sur le plus de
titres sur la je ne vais pas
d'hésitation sedan balle sur ses dents
mathieu vous à pied je crois un sujet de
mémoire qu'était la poésie libertines ou
xviie siècle exact le très bien la forme
et pourquoi alors ça je me suis dit je
crois que c'était un sujet où les
libertés ne vous savez au xviie siècle
ça n'est pas le libertinage telle que
nous l'entendons aujourd'hui c'était
déjà un peu la libre pensée est plutôt
les contestataires
les rénovateurs une certaine
continuellement voilà alors nous allons
revenir politique puisque vous parlez
des contestataires
vous êtes l'homme de la glace ne vous
l'avais dit tout à l'heure c'est
vraiment sur nos mémoires 288 nous
disions encore avant la fin 89 le rpr
bras fait peau neuve
bon alors là il est en train de faire
peau neuve à grande vitesse pas
exactement comme je le pense walla est
ce que c'est comme ça vous l'attendiez
pas précisé mais toujours le répète
et si vous n'avez pas l'impression quand
même fier tout sous un petit peu coupé
l'herbe sous le pied pas du tout je ne
cesse de répéter toutes mes déclarations
publiques en porte témoignage qu'il faut
l'union ils disent qu'il faut l'union
nous avons un désaccord c'est vrai sur
qui doit conduire l'union
ce n'est pas une différence
philosophique très grands noms m'enfin
je me demandais si vous n'étiez pas
secrétaire général du rpr est ce que
vous seriez pas tenter de les rejoindre
ça c'est une question que je pourrais me
poser mais je suis secrétaire général du
rpr et mon rôle c'est la synthèse vous
voulez pas visage il ne peut pas on est
vraiment désolé je ne suis pas
schizophrène voyez je ne peux pas les
imaginer ce que je ferais si je n'étais
pas ce que je suis vous avez raison
c'est vrai qu'en 1984 j'étais le premier
à dire à l'époque qu'il faut un
remaniement ministériel au rp
l'expression que j'avais utilisé par les
tracas vous dire que c'est tout avait
senti passer c'est vrai à l'époque au
rpr connaît aujourd'hui
on m'avait vigoureusement penser oui
alors je vais vous demander si vous êtes
monté dans cette galère de la liste des
européennes par devoir ou par choix
je note c'est plutôt par devoir non par
conviction je crois à l'europe très bien
beau de l'europe parlant des verts le
succès des verts en politique
récemment en france dans des verres en
france est ce que c'est pour vous un
désaveu pour la classe politique
comment l'interprétez vous est ce que ça
veut dire que la caisse publique n'ait
pas su prendre en main les problèmes
d'environnement occupe beaucoup d'autres
reprennent un peu d'originalité
peut-être à tort mais c'est ce que tout
le monde dit tout le monde dit le succès
des verts c'est le désaveu de la classe
politique moi je ne crois pas je crois
que le succès des verts c'est tout
simplement l'expression par un grand
nombre de français de préoccupation
d'angoise parfois qu'ils ressentent ne
le prenons pas sous un aspect
politiciens ne le prenons pas sous un
aspect négatif l'on rejette quelque
chose moi je le prends d'une façon
positive
c'est une fille qui a 15 ans et qui
chaque fois j'observe qu'elle regarde la
télévision et qu'elle voit la
déforestation en amazonie
les images d'otaries ou deux oiseaux que
l'on voit en alaska couvert de bitume et
d'autres choses encore et bien je vois
que ça la frappe que cela touche je
crois que c'est ce qui s'est passé à
lorient n'a pas quinze ans pardon même
si on peut être dans cette génération
plus que plus que dans la nôtre nous ne
l'étions pas au même âge n'était pas
sensibilisé à ces questions là et c'est
pour cela que nous devons alors pendant
considération c'est pour être écologique
et à tous les niveaux
ça commence au niveau de la commune
écologie c'est la propreté ces espaces
verts c'est la conception de la ville
comme on construit ce qu'on fait des
vilains livrable avec des tours et des
barres ou est-ce qu'on fait des
quartiers qui sont accueillants ce que
nous essayons de faire à paris depuis
quelques années l'écologie c'est aussi
le niveau national il ya des normes à
poser il faut sur le bruit sur la
pollution de l'air être plus rigoureux
que ne l'est et puis l'écologie c'est
aussi le niveau planétaire
moi je crois je les dis
nissan aux journées parlementaires qui
va y avoir deux grands combats dans
l'est dans les vingt ou trente années
qui viennent au niveau mondial c'est le
combat pour le développement il est déjà
là qui le combat pour l'environnement
eh bien il faut aller plus loin et plus
fort est peut-être vous surprendre parce
qu'on dit toujours je suis un économiste
que pour moi les chiffres ont beaucoup
d'importance je trouve qu'il ne faut pas
se laisser intoxiquer par les puissances
économiques dans ce domaine il est
scandaleux qu'on continue à laisser se
promener sur toutes les mers du globe
des pétroliers qui transportent des
hydrocarbures dans les conditions on les
transporte
il faut que les pays concernés y en a
pas beaucoup c'est un grossiste impose
aux compagnies pétrolières est un super
technicien
je ne sais pas simple je ne sais pas
honteux de changer la construction de
bateaux on peut peut-être changer des
routes maritimes
on peut peut-être faire escorter cessé
d'être je dis qu'on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça et si ça coûte plus
cher si ça coûte un centime de plus aux
litres d'essence il faut le faire voilà
un exemple il ne faut pas je le répète
se laisser intoxiquer par les grandes
compagnies pétrolières et para les
intérêts économiques
je dirai la même chose sur excusez moi
monsieur beaucoup de passion pour cet
effet écologique marie lanceur d'arrêter
je veux dire la même chose sur
l'industrie automobile
et là je pêche le pardon je bats un peu
ma coulpe nous nous sommes laissés tombe
bien sûr mais ce que j'ai l'air devant
socialiste non plus au début nous nous
sommes laissés trop impressionné par
l'industrie automobile française qui
nous a dit les pots catalytiques sera
sert à nous ruiner
mais je constate que l'industrie
automobile française lorsqu'elle exporte
des voitures françaises dans des pays où
il ya des pots catalytiques elle sait le
faire
alors qu'elle le fasse en france voilà
un domaine où la puissance publique a un
rôle à jouer cette passion pour les
verts ça veut dire que pour vous
vous attendez à l'émergence d'une force
politique comme en allemagne le être en
france s'il pourrait elle n'existe pas
en france il n'ya pas député est ce que
vous voyez que nous allons avoir comme
en allemagne ou en suède par exemple des
députés verts ou par le maire communiste
dans le prochain parlement
je ne crois qu'il fera un bon score aux
élections parce que c'est une action qui
se prête à cela alors simplement celui
d'un même scrutin
si vous voulez vraiment personnellement
si vous souhaitez que ce parti
écologiste et un avenir politique
c'est parce que j'ai dit je ne dis pas
que je le souhaite je dis qu'il aura
peut-être ce que je souhaite c'est que
nos partis à l'intérêt si vous changez
des zones non se passe à la solution la
solution
non non je suis attaché au scrutin
majoritaire et solution c'est que nos
partis à nous le rpr l'udf nous mettions
à la tâche
on m'a beaucoup reproché d'avoir annoncé
entre les deux tours des élections
municipales la nomination d'un
secrétaire nationale à l'environnement
comme la domination était prête je ne
vois pas pourquoi je ne l'aurais pas
annoncer à ce moment là c'est jacques
vernier qui est ici qui est maire de
douai le ville du nord dans lequel ces
problèmes se posent
elle a été responsable de l' agence de
bassin seine normandie île et
parlementaires européens ils siègent à
la commission de l'environnement il
connaît ses problèmes et bien il faut
que l'udf comme le rpr est non seulement
un discours des propositions à faire
en somme vous voulez récupérer
politiquement les verts et voulait pas
changer le mode de scrutin qui leur
permettrait de devenir un vrai parti
politique si souvent mais madame on ne
manipule pas le mode de scrutin pour
permettre l'apparition de force
politique
le mode de scrutin et répond à une
logique la logique politique c'est que
le mode de scrutin est là pour dégager
une majorité
ce que je dis c'est que inexistant il
existe dans certaines élections nos
élections municipales par exemple et
puis s'il grandissent et existeront
aussi aux élections nationales non ce
que je dis c'est que la bonne réponse ne
ramenons pas ça explique pas de le dire
à des considérations très politique je
vous parlais de considération un peu
général je crois que la bonne réponse
est que les partis politiques et les
gouvernements se saisisse de ces
problèmes est que l'opinion publique
fasse pression sur eux pour les plus
qu'ils vont être présents
écologiste au parlement par lui que les
parties soient respectueux de
l'environnement exactement
d'ailleurs ça aide beaucoup et sur
l'europe puisqu'ils seront présents en
europe
bon le vous disiez tout à l'heure il n'y
a pas de divergence vous avez signé un
document commun avec l'udf et aucune
divergence vraiment sur votre conception
européenne
or quand même moins cher lui ces
documents le but de l'udf s'est
clairement disons la philosophie je
parle pas du texte même c'est d'aller
vers les états unis dure d'europe en
renforçant les institutions
communautaires et le rpr lui passe par
beaucoup d'une europe des nations dans
le document final vous parler exactement
de stabiliser le conseil européen de
mieux définir les pouvoirs du conseil
commission du parlement
c'est tout à fait flou qu'est ce que
vous voulez dire avec mieux définir les
pouvoirs est-ce que vous acceptez oui ou
non l'idée d'une europe politique
bien entendu le club même titre qu'il
est bien entendu la vie déficit tout le
monde a fait du chemin
tout le monde vous tout le monde dont
tout le monde a les choses ont beaucoup
évolué et nous ne sommes puis à 30 ans
et vous le voyez la vie politique dans
une fin difficile
si vous me permettez de vous répondre
qu'il veut plus lentement nous faisons
un document commun détaillé qui fixe nos
positions pour les six prochaines années
je ne sais pas ce qui se passera après
et on arrive quand à nous dire mais vous
n'êtes pas d'accord derrière ce document
mais si nous sommes d'accord et je vais
répondre précisément à votre question
sur des institutions
qu'est ce que nous disons disons de
choses il faut renforcer le pouvoir du
parlement parce que c'est là qu'ils
existent la démocratie l'expression des
peuples c'est vrai que les citoyens
d'europe envoient leurs représentants et
nous pensons que le parlement européen
doit avoir davantage de pouvoir par
exemple dans le vote du budget ou dans
la confection du char qui n'existe pas
oui ou dans ceux qui n'existent pas
encore qui sont des lois européennes
vous savez qu'actuellement le parlement
européen ne fait pas de loi quand on
nous parle d'une directive est bien une
directive avait préparé par la
commission c'est à dire par un ensemble
de fonctionnaires nous pensons que le
parlement doit avoir davantage son mot à
dire dans la fabrication de ces lois
européennes et deuxième proposition très
concrète de nous faisons je regrette que
ce crime faisait par un flou nous
faisons une prison très concrètes
nous pensons que le conseil des
ministres doit être stabilisé renforcé à
l'heure actuelle la présidence change
tous les six mois
actuellement c'est l'espagne le 1er
juillet ce sera la france bien nous
pensions qu'il faut donner au président
du conseil européen plus de durée et
nous proposons de le donner pour trois
ans c'est un peu technique mais ça
prouve à quel point nous sommes d'accord
en 13 heures un exemple précis tout
reviendra souvent il faut bien donc
c'est peu il ya un exemple ici est-ce
que vous acceptez par exemple que les
ressortissants des communautés vote pour
les élections locales en france
c'est un problème qui mérite d'être
approfondi ses moyens même si nous ne
sommes pas tout à fait encore au point
dans l'opposition je dirais simplement
qu'il faut modifier la constitution et
que pour l'instant cette proposition se
heurte aux textes de la constitution et
au texte de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen étudions cette
question et on verra après oui donc il
ya encore des points je veux pas rentrer
dans le détail des points d'accord d
accord mais je crois qu'ils subissent
quand même beaucoup de choses sont
encore à mettre mandanda sont d'ailleurs
nous avons pris la même position sur ce
sujet là comme sur les autres
écoutez là je veux vraiment bien insisté
sur ce point le texte il existe il parle
de tout
il parle de la culture il parle de
l'éducation il parle de la défense il
parle des institutions
il parle de l'agriculture il ya dix
politique commune et je voudrais ajouter
quelque chose que je n'ai pas encore dit
c'est qu'il parle aussi de la manière
dont il faut préparer la france à
l'europe parce que massé sont très
inquiets d'être inquiet car l'europe
peut être une très grande chance pour
nous elle peut nous apporter des emplois
que nous apporter de la croissance et de
la richesse
mais c'est vrai qu'elle risque de
menacer certaines catégories
professionnelles
face à cela il ya deux attitudes
possibles la première c'est la ligne
maginot
il nous avons entendu la définition de
la ligne maginot anti-européenne dans la
bouche de monsieur mitterrand il ya
quelques semaines à 7 sur 7 je crois en
février il nous disait il faut se
protéger contre le gangstérisme
internationale l'autre conception c'est
qu'il faut renforcer la proximité à ce
sont ses propres termes il faut
renforcer la france il faut renforcer
les entreprises françaises il faut les
musclés dans la compétition et vous
soyez vous savez tous ces voyages que
j'ai faits à l'étranger à madrid à
londres m'a permis de voir à quel point
les autres se préparer alors que nous
nous ne nous préparons pas et c'est ça
ma grande différence avec le
gouvernement actuel
on n'a pas du tout parlé du gouvernement
de sa politique des socialistes
nous n'avons parlé que de l'opposition
je voudrais dire ici en vain qu'on y
vienne très clairement que nous avons
sur un certain nombre de points
des différences n'ont pas idéologique ou
non pas théologique avec les socialistes
mais des différences de fond sur la
politique qu'il faut mener pour la
france puisque ceux de préparation ils
auraient pu commencer il ya très
longtemps parce que le marché unique de
93 s'est jamais que l'aboutissement du
traité de rome de 57 ans allait qu'on y
allait qu'on dirait non ces mêmes
candidats plutôt bout de chemin
abattus les barrières douanières et
entre 86 et 88 préparation psychologique
donc vous verrez vraiment plus et 88
c'est un point que je veux souligner
parce que c'est ce qui explique que nous
ne soyons mis d'accord assez facilement
avec nos partenaires de l'udf le
gouvernement de jacques chirac a fait
une besogne formidable en matière
européenne en matière de défense c'est
la charte de la défense européenne de
l'union de l'europe occidentale en
matière agricole les paysans qui nous
regardent savent ce qui a été fait en la
matière en matière de recherche nous
avons adoptée à l'époque un programme
quinquennal de recherche en matière
spatiale
hermès la navette européenne elle a été
décidée entre 86 et 90
donc le bilan européen des gouvernements
de jacques chirac de 86 à 88 mais
considérable et vous allez pouvoir n'a
pas été ressentie mais parce que en
novembre 88 quand monsieur chirac a
rectifié l'acte unique
il a dit que c'était pour éviter une
crise dans la majorité et en février 89
vous même vous avez dit qu'il fallait
une liste unique pour donner une
meilleure image et l'opposition qui
mobilisait l'électorat ce soir on a eu
l'impression je pense que l'europe était
peut-être pour le rpr qu'un problème
électoral
non c'est simple si nous allons donner
cette impression je le regrette mais
sachez que ce n'est pas du tout notre
conviction c'est vraiment pour nous
l'europe quelque chose de très important
je ne dirais pas ce que dit monsieur
fabius je crois ou monsieur rocard je
n'ai plus la situation actuelle en tête
ils disent l'europe et l'avenir de la
france je dirais pas ça pour moi
l'avenir de la france et la france mais
c'est l'avenir de la france en europe
quand elle doit être un des éléments
moteurs cette une conviction profonde
qui va se passer des tas de choses dans
les 20 prochaines années croyez bien que
ce n'est pas un enjeu électoral pas du
tout ici tout à l'heure qu'il va falloir
et avoir une politique européenne sur le
plan de la politique étrangère prend
liban par exemple puisque on vous a posé
une question sur le liban est-ce que
vous approuvez l'aide humanitaire qui
vient d'être envoyé au liban
je pense que oui est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils pourraient le plus loin ou pas tu
te sujet difficile vous savez les
dernières informations que les syriens
ou les prosyriens poteau libanais
s'élever violemment contre l'arrivée des
bateaux français à beyrouth et qui sont
même bombardé le port de jounieh
j'ai tellement difficile que moi je ne
ressens pas le droit étant dans
l'opposition n'ayant pas tous les
éléments d'information disponibles de
donner des leçons au gouvernement sur ce
qu'il faut faire ou ne pas faire
parce que je veux dire simplement ce
qu'il faut et j'ai approuvé l'aide
humanitaire comment ne pas approuver
l'aide humanitaire je me signale
d'ailleurs qu'aujourd'hui même le
conseil de paris vient de voter une aide
humanitaire exceptionnelle au liban
c'est un
un problème un drame moi qui me touche
beaucoup et la façon dont je le plus
personnellement et le plus
douloureusement ressenti c'est la
semaine dernière je suis allé avec
beaucoup d'autres devant l'ambassade du
liban
il y avait là des centaines de personnes
et milliers de personnes ce qui m'a
bouleversé
c'est de voir ces hommes et ces femmes
se cramponner à nous en nous disant
merci d'être venus on compte sur vous je
vous cache pas que ça m'a fait quelque
chose de très dur au coeur parce que je
me suis dit mais qu'est ce que je peux
faire pour
ils attendent tous deux nous qu'est-ce
que je peux faire sinon pousser un cri
un cri de révolte un cri d'indignation
devant ce martyr
et puis soutenir toutes les initiatives
qui pourront être prises mais là il faut
vraiment que les français se mobilisent
voyez m'est venu une idée ce n'est
peut-être que qu'une mauvaise idée ça
n'est peut-être qu'une idée trop
médiatique mais après tout vivant dans
un monde médiatique pendant des mois
c'était une bonne initiative la
télévision faisait apparaître sur ses
écrans dans les journaux télévisés la
photo des otages français au liban est
ce qu'on ne pourrait pas chaque jour
dire voilà le martyre du liban voilà on
a les morts liban voilà depuis combien
de temps dure cette agression contre un
peuple qui a droit à l'indépendance à la
liberté et à la paix
bien sûr vous avez été mais qu'est-ce
que vous comment vous réagissez à la
proposition que font aujourd'hui
messieurs soustelle d'ormesson et je
crois
coste floret qui demande au président de
la république zine publicité publiée par
le monde d'envoyer un bateau au liban
pour rapt pour ramener en france les
personnes âgées les femmes et les
enfants qui souhaiteraient quitter le
liban
c'est quelque chose d'envisageable ça
nous avons déjà envoyé un bateau qui
portent des médicaments est vite arrivé
il ya des difficultés vous savez pour
l'accostage de ce bateau parce que les
syriens de l'îlot des règles
obligatoires et tient tout à fait alors
que
nous voulons aider l'ensemble des
communautés du libre cette initiative
mérite qu'on y réfléchisse faut-il vider
le liban je suis pas sûr que ce soit la
bonne formule jacques chirac a fait
trois propositions qui n'ont
malheureusement pas encore été suivies
d'effet qui sont concrètes bien que
n'est pas exclusivement l'aspect
humanitaire dont nous parlons première
proposition
il souhaite que nous saisissions le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
dont nous sommes membres pour que le
conseil de sécurité exige un cessez le
feu
il peut le faire la deuxième chose que
jacques chirac a demandé c'est une
réunion du conseil européen de
l'ensemble des 12 pays pour qu'ils
parlent sur ce sujet et qu'il fasse des
propositions et la troisième chose que
nous avons demandé c'est la réunion
d'une conférence internationale avec la
cigogne liban l'urss les grandes
puissances pour essayer de trouver une
solution
moi j'ai connu le liban en 73 avant la
guerre civile c'était un pays
extraordinaire qui reposait sur l'
équilibre miraculeux des communautés
religieuses culturelles linguistiques
tout ceci s'est effondré dans cette
espèce de long martyre qu'on vit depuis
des années il faut vraiment que la
communauté internationale se mobilise et
moi j'appellerai pour être bon d'avoir
tué 186 est qu elles sont assistées 88
vous n'avez pas tenu ce langage et vous
n'avez pas beaucoup bougé je sais que
vous étiez assis ligotés par problème
des otages
est ce qu'au fond c'est pas ça parce que
c'est pas les la crainte du terrorisme
ce qui va les otages qui vise à empêcher
les vers une politique plus active si
vous n'avez pas une politique dont je
prends mon gouvernement je crois qu'on
ne peut pas dire cela
nous avons toujours dit on les a fait
douter nous avons toujours dit que nous
n'avons pas été suffisamment
d'initiative le veut bien accepter
toutes les critiques mais jamais nous
n'avons tenu un autre langage que celui
que je vous tiens jamais mené à non mais
je suis très choqué je suis très
affirmatif madame sur ce point jamais
nous n'avons cessé de dire que le liban
avait droit à l'intégrité de son
territoire à l'indépendance de la nation
et à la paix et nous avons toujours
essayé de tout faire en ce sens entre je
crois que là-dessus tout a été très
clair peut-être la situation entre 86 et
n'at-elle pas connu d des paroxysmes
comme dernière que nous avons depuis
quelques temps une dernière question qui
sera est-ce que vous approuvez la venue
d'un fatah paris je suis déjà exprimé
sur ce point et j'ai répondu qu'elle me
paraissait prématurée pourquoi il se
passe beaucoup de choses au proche
orient depuis quelques mois nous afp oui
mais je vais vous dire comment je les
interprète donc il n'est pas question
pour moi de dire ne bougeons pas tout
est figé dont il se passe des choses
l'ol paie pour être plus précis a
officiellement renoncé au terrorisme et
le lp a reconnu implicitement
l'existence d'israël explicite je crois
que ça n'est ce pas aussi explicite est
aussi clair que quand on veut bien le
dire
alors il faut tenir compte de ces
évolutions et nos amis américains en
tenu compte
il faut qu'il y ait des contacts qu'ils
soient pris au niveau diplomatique c'est
tout à fait nécessaire la france aussi
doit-on prendre au niveau diplomatique
solenniser cela par une réception par le
président de la république à un moment
où nous n'avons pas pu vraiment mettre à
l'épreuve des faits cette bonne volonté
nouvelle de l'ol paie cela me semble une
initiative prématurée je ne dis pas
qu'il ne faut pas les faire je crois que
les prématurés la durée à dire la durée
voulait encore attendre oui à sept morts
moi j'en fais a fait des morts chaque
jour de suppression
je ne suis pas sûr madame que la
réception de monsieur arafat par le
président de la république française
fort assez sélectif aboutissement si ça
devait la faire cesser alors là je
réviserai mal position c'est quand même
que notre position là dessus est
beaucoup plus frileuses et je pense
aussi par exemple à celle que vous avez
sur monsieur gorbatchev vous ne faites
pas tout à fait confiants sont plus
puisqu'elle n'est quand même pas
beaucoup plus frileuses que celle que
rue par exemple général de quick ou que
celle qu'il a eue alors moir l'algérie
une règle que je me suis fixé depuis que
je fais de la politique je sais que je
vais je n'ai pour ma part jamais
l'impertinence de faire paraître général
de cour je sais pas ce qu'il aurait fait
vous savez il ya des domaines
ils ont été lâchement quand il s'agit de
la de la survie d'une nation de son
indépendance nationale de sa défense
pour il faut être prudent
moi je suis assez
ouvert aux changements on en a beaucoup
parlé mais sur ce sujet là je serai peut
être un peu frileux et avant d'entrer
dans la maison et je le reconnais avant
d'entrer dans la maison commune de
monsieur gorbatchev
là aussi je veux vérifier un certain
nombre de choses et il serait très utile
que nous le vérifions ensemble parce que
on peut aussi se demander si monsieur
gorbatchev n'utilise pas ce que nous
avons connu lorsque nous étions
étudiants en expliquant les tragédies
classiques c'est-à-dire la méthode des
horaces et des curiaces on nous divisons
fait courir les uns et puis ceux qui
sont à la traîne
on les met sous influence je crois qu'on
aurait tout intérêt à se mettre ensemble
à bien réfléchir ensemble sur ces
problèmes avant de baisser notre garde
vous savez ça c'est pas un problème
économique
un problème économique on peut toujours
le rattraper si on dépense trop d'argent
ou mal on peut toujours attraper le
problème de l'indépendance de la france
de l'europe de nos libertés
fondamentales de nos régimes
démocratiques
cela demande peut-être pas de la
frilosité mais beaucoup de prudence à
fait d'accord avec monsieur gillett si
j'allais vous dire europe des douze pour
vous et pas en 10 ans les inconnus ont
bien sûr que non pas de maison commune
comme monsieur gorbatchev la crau choix
ça affirmatif
en revanche le développement des
relations avec les pays de l'est c'est
pas un gaulliste et qui vous dira le
contraire
bien sûr je crois qu'il faut pas
caricaturer ses problèmes diplomatiques
sont extrêmement complexes je dis qu'il
faut de la prudence je dis qu'il faut
que l'europe ait sa propre capacité de
défense tant que nous n'aurons pas
abouti un désarmement véritablement
équilibré et je dis qu'il faut bien sûr
intensifier les relations avec tous ces
pays qui sont en train de bouger
regarder ce qui se passe en pologne est
quand même extraordinaire a bien sûr
qu'il faut y aller les aider
problème vous aurez toujours n'ai pas le
sentiment
merci merci chose est elle viable alors
l'opinion des français sur ce dont on a
parlé
les revendications des fonctionnaires
corps alors d'une prime d'insularité
vous par estelle justifier ou excessives
c'est pas à vous qu'on pose la question
c'est aux français mais je vous poserai
l'a posté ensuite 12% justifié 74%
excessive 14 % sans opinion
alors vous qui avez été ministre des
finances ou pensez quoi je crois que le
problème est mal posé
je crois que le gouvernement a
effectivement raison de mener une
politique globale de la fonction
publique et de ne pas lâcher ici vous la
déprime qui risquerait d'avoir un effet
de contagion
mais je crois qu'il faut poser le
problème d'ensemble du développement
économique de la corse et je suis très
inquiet sur ce domaine je dois vous le
dire on nous parle beaucoup de la
méthode rocard en me disant qu'elle est
très efficace en matière de problème
corse la méthode record a été
désastreuse
c'est un problème qu'on a laissé pourrir
monsieur charasse a tenu des propos
inconsidérés à l'égard des corses qui se
sont sentis humiliés
on les a présentés comme des gens qui
piquait dans la poche du contribuable
tout simplement
et ceci est en train de produire des
évolutions très grave en corse au départ
c'était une revendication économique
avec des syndicats et c'est en train de
devenir une sorte de mouvement
faut bien le dire c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui vers les autonomistes qui
récupère la situation a je crois que là
il fallait faire sa méthode il fallait
faire croire qu'il fallait engager
je crois qu'il fallait engager le
dialogue beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup
plus globalement pour essayer d'aller
plus loin dans le redressement
économique de la corse le gouvernement
de jacques chirac avait commencé à faire
quelque chose
nous avions prévu certaines exonérations
fiscales nous avions prévu des crédits
importants pour les investissements
routiers portuaires aéroportuaires
eh bien je crois qu'on a eu tort de ne
pas continuer dans cette direction sur
ce point précis je suis très sévère sur
la façon dont d'aussi a été conduit dans
le gouvernement sur l'europe alors
est-ce que qui a converti l'autre dans
l'homme dans le couple infernal faire
votre avis le nbr le rpr qui s'est
rallié au vu de l'udf l'udf qui s'est
rallié au vu du rpr dont les gens ont le
sentiment que le rpr a fait un peu de
chemin quand même vers l'udf 34% pensent
que c'est le rpr il a fait le bout de
chemin 14 pensant que c'est l'udf et
comme ce sujet quand même très technique
52%
les français n'ont pas d'opinion mais ce
n'est pas si simple non c'est pas ça des
questions des téléspectateurs jean-louis
la scène oui alain juppé certains de vos
amis du rpr et l'udf ont pris des jeunes
beurs sur leur liste aux dernières
municipales qu'en pensez vous écoutez
moi je suis comme le disait tout à l'air
madame josette alia discret de nature et
je ne me suis pas vantée par tous
d'avoir fait la même chose
j'ai pourtant ici à mes côtés je ne sais
pas où il est je crois qu'il est dans la
salle un jeune français d'origine
musulmane il s'appelle hervé mechri il
est là il était sur ma liste et jacques
chirac en a même fait un adjoint au
maire de paris chargé de la jeunesse
c'est donc vous dire que nous avons fait
beaucoup sans tambour ni trompette dans
ce domaine
autre question si vous nous parliez de
l'immigration dans le contexte européen
certains pays comme l'espagne se refuse
à toute immigration avec ses 20% de
chômeurs est ce qu'on pourrait envisager
la même chose en france
je ne suis pas sûr que la situation soit
exactement celle là en espagne mais je
sais que c'est un problème grave dont
nous devons parler ensemble quand je
suis allé à madrid j'ai rencontré le
ministre de l'intérieur et j'en ai
longuement parlé avec lui il y
actuellement des concertations entre les
12 pays de la communauté est ce que m'a
dit le ministre espagnol qui siège dans
un gouvernement socialiste
cela mérite d'être souligné c'est qu'il
était irresponsable de supprimer les
frontières entre les douze états de la
communauté avant d'avoir instauré à
l'extérieur de la communauté une
véritable politique commune de lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine et de
lutte bien sûr contre le trafic de
drogue ou le terrorisme
je crois qu'il ya là une prise de
conscience nous savons très bien quand
pays comme la grèce n'a pas du tout en
ce temps cette matière les mêmes
exigences que nous bien nous ne pouvons
pas progressé dans la libération
intégrale des échanges entre les pays de
la communauté tant que nous n'aurons pas
fait quelque chose ensemble dans ce
domaine et cela figure excusez moi de le
rajouter bien sûr dans la déclaration
prévue du rpr et l'udf nous sommes tout
à fait d'accord sur ce point vous avez
croyez-vous toujours vraiment à
strasbourg capitale européenne lorsque
l'on voit les travaux entrepris à
bruxelles on peut se demander si
strasbourg
ce sera un jour et est ce que nous
français nous avons pas une
responsabilité importante dans ce
transfert éventuel
sans doute mais vous savez la meilleure
manière d'échouer dans la vie c'est de
ne pas croire quand vous me demandez si
je crois oui je crois je crois qu'il
faut tout faire parce que c'est
l'intérêt de la france et d'une certaine
manière c'est aussi l'intérêt de
l'europe de garder strasbourg capitale
européenne si on baisse les bras avant
d'avoir mené des batailles on est sûr de
ne pas remporter la bataille
nous allons débattre là dessus tout à
l'heure vous êtes intervenu quand j'ai
dit résider à strasbourg je voulais dire
travailler et vivre cela heureusement
ils vivent suffisamment pour être
présent dans les débats il semble que
bien que c'est pas tellement ce que nous
faisons nous français par rapport à
l'assiduité des autres non je crois
qu'il ya effectivement des problèmes des
primes de communication aérienne qui ne
sont pas aussi comme de si fréquentes
qu'il faudrait et tout ça ce sont des
problèmes techniques il faut
véritablement que le gouvernement
français
et voilà un sujet de consensus je ne
vois pas qui pourrait être contre la
défense de strasbourg capitale
européenne on nous parle à tout bout de
champ de rassembler opposition et
majorité
rassemblons nous sur ce thème c'est un
enjeu national pour lequel tous les
français devrait se réduire mais le
sentiment c'est que si on s'était
rassemblée ya quelques années peut-être
commencera par la loi mais mutuellement
albert du roy
on enchaîne pour un quart d'heure un
quart d'heure comme duhamel un bon quart
d'heure oui je me demandais quand je
voyais la question posée par la sofres
qu'elle ait dû de l'udf ou du rpr celui
qui a fait le plus de chemin l'un vers
l'autre
je me demandais quel aurait été votre
réponse match nul coté je n'ai pas
observé que dans nos déclarations avec
l'udf dans nos conversations avec l'udf
personnes et revendiquait de la part
d'edf
la réalisation dans les six années qui
viennent d'une fédération européenne
avec un gouvernement unique et une
intégration politique totale mais peut
quand même se souvenir que dans le début
des années 60
certains
mouvements politiques qui sont
aujourd'hui à l'udf je pense en
particulier aux centristes étaient sur
cette idée de la fédération des états
unis d'europe
aujourd'hui tout le monde a beaucoup
évolué et nous avons évolué je le
reconnais bien volontiers tout
simplement c'est un de près d'un bois
sur lequel vous n'avez pas tout à fait
le même avis que monsieur giscard
d'estaing puisque lui s'est félicité du
chemin parcouru par le rpr je n'ai pas
dit le contraire monsieur des rois j'ai
dit que nous avons parcouru du chemin
jeudi que certaines composantes de l'udf
ont aussi parcouru beaucoup de chemin
alors je vous en donne un exemple est ce
qu'il faut aller au fond des choses il y
a quelques années quelques décennies
peut-être certains certaines
personnalités politiques qui siègent
aujourd'hui à l'udf voulait transformer
la commission bruxelles excusez moi de
rentrer un peu dans la technique
gouvernements européens plus personne ne
le demande aujourd'hui est ce que il
n'ya pas là notamment dans tous ceux qui
se réclament du gaullisme vraiment un
clivage génération quand vous réclamez
aujourd'hui plus de pouvoir pour les
différents échelons du pouvoir européen
ça nécessite un transfert de pouvoir de
la nation de l'état vers l'europe
est ce que c'est quelque chose que la
famille gaulliste aurait accepté il ya
quelques années et est ce que
aujourd'hui encore ce n'est pas vraiment
l'un qui vaches de fonds entre vous
écoutez moi je réponds dans l'autre
famille je répond affirmativement à la
question doit vous ne demandez est ce
que la famille gaulliste l'aurait
acceptée je dis oui elle l'a acceptée
aujourd'hui
non elle l'accepté dans le passé
souvenons nous qui a voulu la politique
agricole commune
le général de gaulle dans les années 60
qu'est ce que c'est que la politique
agricole commune
c'est la première politique dans lequel
nous avons abandonné notre souveraineté
et pour parler plus clair devant les
français qui nous écoutent ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui le prix
des pommes de terre ou le prix du blé ou
le prix des légumes que nous consommons
ils ne sont plus fixés par des autorités
nationales françaises ces prix sont
fixés à bruxelles par une instance qui
est en cet écran serait le peuple et que
pour les pommes de terre
non j'ai l'exemple ce qu'il parlait
parlait à l'imagination de chacun bien
entendu on fait il ya des règlements
communautaires sur à peu près tous les
produits
ces prix d'intervention sont fixés à
bruxelles et je le répète c'est un
abandon de souveraineté dont voyez que
le général de gaulle non seulement elle
a accepté mais qu'il l'a voulu alors il
faut continuer quand hôtel sans pour
autant bien sûr abandonné l'idée
parce que on dit souvent excusez moi de
saisir l'occasion de le dire mais avec
tout ça qu'est ce qui vous sépare des
socialistes moi je dirais que vis-à-vis
des socialistes je suis plus libérale
année konami
je suis plus attaché à la réalité
nationale je suis plus novateurs sur
certains phénomènes de société en
particulier l'éducation
je suis peut-être plus attachés à
certaines valeurs traditionnelles comme
les valeurs familiales
ça mériterait peut-être une émission
mais je voulais le pré saison de mai
mais est ce qu'on peut que tirer de ces
différences que vous soulignez le fait
qu'aujourd'hui entre vous et les
socialistes il n'y a plus qu'on appelait
jadis est un choix de société
jadis naguère il reste en vigueur non
186 je crois que les choses ont changé
indubitablement en 81
les socialistes avaient un programme
d'inspiration marxiste il avait une
alliance avec les communistes
alors eux ils ont changé pour le
couronnement des critères qui a le plus
changé le rpr udf non ceux qui ont fait
les plus grands chemins ce sont les
socialistes
il n'en reste pas moins lors de ce point
de vue là nous n'avons plus ce clivage
idéologique un peu théologique disais
tout à l'heure qui existaient il ya 10
ou 15 ans mais il reste les différences
s'il n'y avait pas de différence moi je
serai dans une espèce de pot commun
socialo je ne sais trop quoi je ne suis
pas socialiste car j'ai des différences
j'en prends une qui me paraît
extrêmement importante si nous étions au
pouvoir
nous ne ferions pas la même politique
économique que le gouvernement à l'heure
actuelle nous n'aurions pas fait le
budget qui a été fait pour 89 n'augmente
aurions pas les dépenses publiques comme
les socialistes et les augmente
doubey serions les impôts nous
continuerions les privatisations
ça ça fait une politique vente est
différent
mais ce n'est pas un problème économique
ça pas du tout bien sûr que non puisque
nous n'avions même proposer monsieur de
virieu pendant la campagne électorale de
jacques chirac est la seule sottise que
nous ayons fait parce qu'il arrive à
tout le monde d'en faire c'est de ne pas
l'avoir fait plus tôt
simplement nous l'aurions fait
différemment et nous aurions mis je ne
sais plus qui a utilisé cette formule un
point plus fort sur le i de rmi c'est à
dire que nous aurions bâti véritablement
un système de réinsertion des gens qui
touchent le rmi et à qui il faut
proposer autre chose que l'espérance de
continuer à aller au guichet pendant 30
pendant 10 ans pour toucher le rmi
flancs présentent et l'espérance d'un
métier d'une réinsertion sociale mais
sur la philosophie
je suis tout à fait d'accord et ça c'est
un point que je voudrais dire à monsieur
du royaume mais je suis sociable rentrer
malgré l'interruption mon ami france
parvient c'est pas moi qui vous
interrompt pour reprendre le col devrait
deux petites précisions sur l'europe et
puis après on passe à ces problèmes là
quand vous parliez tout à l'heure du
renforcement que vous étiez souhaitable
de des pouvoirs du parlement européen
est ce que est ce que ce n'est pas une
autre façon de se méfier un peu de la
commission européenne je dire de la
commission présidée actuellement par
jacques delors
c'est une façon de la vivre au cra sivos
el-houari aussi si vous parlez de la
bureaucratie bruxelloise où il était le
comédien je la connais un petit peu
nous avons fait de gros efforts en
france et d'autres pays européens ont
fait des efforts en ce sens pour alléger
nos propres bureaucratie nationale si
nous substituer à ces bureaucraties
nationale des service de fonctionnaires
bruxellois qui connaîtront bien sûr
moins bien les réalités encore que ne
les connaissent les bureaucrates
nationaux mais nous n'aurons pas gagné
au change
où est la démocratie en europe où est-ce
que s'exprime la volonté des peuples ou
est-ce qu'on peut consulter les gens
c'est à l'occasion des élections
européennes qui nous permettent de
désigner le parlement et par ailleurs
c'est au conseil européen puisque au
conseil européen siège des ministres qui
sont eux-mêmes des élus de la nation
la commission elle est là pour avoir une
eau un rôle d'impulsion de propositions
de gestion parfois mais ce ne doit pas
être l'amorcé d'un gouvernement européen
l'élection du président de cette
commission au suffrage universel ça
change complètement la nature de
l'institution on bascule dans un autre
système et ce n'est pas celui que nous
avons envisagée avec l élection d un
président de l'europe au suffrage
universel
vous savez l'europe va pas se faire en
six ans faudra 12 18 24
des élections européennes nous n'avons
pas retenu cette idée pour l'immédiat
mais peut-être que le problème se posera
dans quelques années
dernière toutes les questions sur
l'europe les élus de cette liste unique
rpr udf que vous souhaitez s qui
figureront dans le même groupe
parlementaire à strasbourg
je le souhaite c'est un sujet écrit en
algérie avant l'instant non c'est vrai
mais vous savez il faut corriger ces
erreurs
à l'heure actuelle qu'est ce qui se
passe à strasbourg la france ne pèse pas
ce qu'elle devrait peser au parlement
européen elle pèse beaucoup moins que
les britanniques ou que les allemands
j'ai été moi-même parlementaires
européens déjà gelée était entre 84 et
86 j'ai cessé de l'être quand je suis
rentré au gouvernement puisqu'il y avait
incompatibilité et pourquoi est ce que
nous ne pesons pas suffisamment bien
parce que nous sommes dispersés dans
plusieurs groupes ya je crois au moins
trois groupes je parle sous le contrôle
d'un roger chinaud qui est égale qui a
été parlementaire européen bien je crois
que ce n'est pas ça et nous avons dit
avec l'udf lorsque nous en avons parlé
que nous allions étudier comment nous
allions pouvoir nous regrouper dans le
même groupe on va étudier ça dans les
prochains jours tout à l'heure quand
vous parliez des différences que vous
aviez avec les socialistes vous ne vais
pas sauf si j'étais distrait n'avait pas
évoqué votre une conception différente
du rôle de l'état est vrai qu'on dit
qu'on irait une passe quelque chose qui
me fera bien livre qui est paru il ya
quelques semaines qui s'appelle je crois
la république bananière et un livre qui
va sortir dans quelques jours qui
s'appelle l'état hors la loi et ses deux
livres pour être schématique raconte
tout ce que des gouvernements d
administration la fonction publique en
général de droite comme de gauche commet
commirent et d'une irrégularité comac du
pouvoir comme tout les toutes les choses
qu'on peut leur reprocher c'est un
procès de l'état en france
de droite comme de gauche j'assiste est
ce que là il n'y a pas une réforme
fondamentale à laquelle tout le monde
devrait s'attacher
mais là quelle peut-être des hommes
politiques comme vous qui quittent des
produits de la fonction publique pour la
plupart vous êtes très mal placé pour
vous êtes vais attaquer peut-être qu'on
ne remplace par d'autres s'ils sont
meilleurs c'est au suffrage d'en décider
nous avons tous été élus
je crois qu'il ya un grand problème là
c'est vrai que la réforme de l'état
c'est un vrai problème
je me bornerai à dire deux choses
premièrement pour leurs efforts mais il
ne faut pas le faire grossir
indéfiniment tel qu'il est parce que
lorsqu'on a déjà un monstre un peu
graisseux si l'obésité augmente ça
n'arrange rien et c'est ce que nous
avons essayé de faire entre 86 et 88
alain madelin en particulier dans son
secteur gérard longuet aussi c'est de
redynamiser la fonction places gratuites
mais je languis réussi à diminuer le
nombre d'employés il avait engagé
permettez-moi de le dire bien des
réformes d'abord il les a diminué le
ministre du budget de l'époque vous le
dire et ensuite il est anglais je
l'avais un peu poussé et il a engagé
bien des réformes de fond en particulier
l'introduction de la participation dans
ses services
donc nous avions engagé la réforme de
l'état et dans une perspective qui était
un léger amaigrissement parce qu'il
fallait bien et en même temps une
rénovation et puis la deuxième chose que
je voudrais dire et je voudrais prendre
sur ce point un exemple qui me tient
beaucoup à coeur qui est celui de
l'éducation michèle alliot marie est
également présente sur ce plateau elle
s'est occupée de ses problèmes sous le
gouvernement de jacques chirac
voyez que j'ai autour de moi oui vous
avez une été je crois presque infini
équipe qui n'est pas composée
d'octogénaires 1 quand je parle de
michèle alliot marie de vernis etc
les jeunes gens ont failli il ya
beaucoup de jeunes autour de moi mon
gouvernement entre guillemets au rpr et
doit avoir une moyenne d'âge de 40 ans
c'est très jeune
enfin ce qu'on prend la parenthèse nous
revenons à notre débat je voulais
évoquer un sujet qui me tient beaucoup à
coeur c'est celui de l'éducation
j'ai bien écouté ce qu'a dit monsieur
j'ose pas ce qu'a dit monsieur rocard et
je l'écoutais avec beaucoup de bonne
volonté j'ai même dit au départ sur
beaucoup d'orientation je suis d'accord
l'idée qu'il fallait à motiver un peu ce
secteur je suis d'accord
l'idée qu'il fallait l'ouvrir davantage
sur le monde de l'entreprise
je suis d'accord c'est ce que nous avons
essayé le faire et puis ce qui m'a
frappé ensuite à la manière dont va
évoluer le dossier c'est que tout s'est
figé et on ne parle plus du système
éducatif en france qu'en termes
d'augmentation des rémunérations d'une
armée de fonctionnaires de très grande
qualité souvent et d'une armée d'un
million de fonctionnaires
si nous prenons cette structure comme lé
sens la change
en nous contentant d'y injecter jugé
mettant des chevalets jusqu'au bout
parce que c'est très important d'y
injecter des moyens supplémentaires et
bien là aussi nous serons de la mauvaise
graisse
il faut changer les structures et voilà
un point sur lequel je suis en total
accord parce que nous l'avions dit
d'ailleurs en même temps ou avant avec
alain carignon qui a expliqué sa n'y a
pas très longtemps dans une émission de
radio
il faut décentraliser le système
éducatif qui peut le mieux aider les
enfants qui sont en septième en sixième
à lutter contre l'échec scolaire
c'est-à-dire à se perfectionner dans la
lecture et l'écriture
sinon les communes parce qu'elles
peuvent mettre sur le terrain des
associations qui feront du soutien
scolaire
de même en matière
d'enseignement supérieur ça va peut-être
faire bondir ici ou là moi je n'ai
aucune objection à ce qu'on donne aux
régions davantage de pouvoirs pour créer
des universités qui seront ensuite des
universités concurrence
c'est comme ça que ça bougera voilà un
grand une grande réforme de l'état la
voyez où il est très mal en flexion au
sein du rpr sur l'éducation
où en est son travail nous démarrons
michèle barzach y est associé aussi en
tant que responsable ce secteur de la
réflexion avec que michèle alliot-marie
ça démarre le 15 avril de voiliers je
voulais simplement dire que tout ça
c'est pas du baratin un homme enfin
celle du roi du temps nous étions au
gouvernement les gouvernements ont eu
des problèmes avec will délogera l'hiver
c'est aussi avec l'école l'université
est-ce que deux questions en une seule
est ce qu'on peut et est ce qu'un
gouvernement n'importe lequel peut
réformer l'éducation nationale avec les
enseignants et est ce qu'un gouvernement
peut le réformer sans les enseignants ou
pas ce que je peux répondre oui mais on
peut commencer la question clé parce que
sinon on peut commencer à se poser la
question vaut naturellement pas réformer
l'éducation sans les anciens je crois
qu'il ne faut pas réformer l'éducation
nationale en se disant le 1er janvier de
l'année
voilà dans six mois nous allons
appliquer l'éducation nationale une
nouvelle réforme globale qui va
permettre de changer les choses il faut
introduire dans ce système qui
complètement bloquée j'espère de faire
offense à personne en le disant et
surtout pas aux enseignants qui est
extrêmement conservateur parce qu'il ya
des réactions un petit peu de crainte
il faut introduire des ferments de
novation voilà la rénovation des
ferments de concurrence des ferments là
aussi de décentralisation quand nous
étions au gouvernement nous avions pris
je ne sais plus combien je crois que
c'est une centaine de mesures de
déconcentration qui visait à faire
prendre non plus à paris mais sur le
terrain toute une série de décisions il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin et on nous
parle de l'europe
regardez l'angleterre regardez
l'allemagne regardez encore d'autres
pays nulle part ailleurs qu'en france on
a un système qui est gérée de la tête
comme il l'est de la rue de grenelle en
france il ya là quelque chose qu'il faut
changer
par petites touches en laissant faire
les choses oui la rue de grenelle en ce
qui concerne les libertés nationales la
rue de rivoli où vous siégiez en ce qui
concerne les finances
l'idée vous savez que monsieur balladur
a été le premier ministre de l'éducation
2 pardon de l'économie à s'amputer quand
monsieur balladur a privatisé il s'est
privé de grands pouvoirs quand monsieur
balladur a créé le conseil de la
concurrence et à renoncer à un certain
nombre de prérogatives qui étaient les
siennes
il s'est privé de grand pouvoir tout ça
pour vous dire que la politique que nous
avons fait ça n'était pas la même que
celle qui est faite aujourd'hui j'ai la
faiblesse de penser qu'elle était
meilleure genre j'en reviens un instant
à ma république bananière et à mon état
hors la loi quand les rénovateurs parle
de de morale de morale politique
est ce que ce n'est pas un peu aux abus
de l'état qu'ils font allusion est ce
que ce n'est pas l'une de leur
originalité par rapport aux autres
ou est ce que c'est quelque chose que
vous partagez tout est fait mais je ne
vois aucune originalité sur ce point non
j'adhère complètement de même que je
voulais le dire tout à l'heure vous
voyez ça me revient la suite si tu fais
parfois nous parler de ce qui me
distingue des socialistes sur les
objectifs de la politique sociale ont
parlé de leurs amis moi j'ai aucune
différence il faut quand même qu'on
sorte de cette idée complètement
dépassée selon laquelle les inscrits
plus haut sur que les autres moi
j'adhère pleinement à tous les objectifs
de solidarité et de justice
j'ai pas de différence est due à propos
de l'économie à propos des problèmes
sociaux le le nombre des foyers fiscaux
exonérés de l'impôt sur le revenu est en
france beaucoup plus élevé qu'en
allemagne angleterre que presque partout
dans les pays européens
comment est-ce qu'on harmonise ça ça
c'est une des marottes vous voyez pas ce
que je crois je le dis j'espère ne pas
vous
nous irriter où vous blesser je crois
que c'est une des idées les plus
répandus en france et en même temps les
plus fausses c'est vrai plaisir à votre
ami liotard qui étaient là ya pas si
longtemps et qu'il avait je suis sûr que
si je mens d'expliquer avec françois
léotard n'entendrions d'accord j'avais
pas complet sur le sida compris je n'ai
pas de leçon et souvenir d'aucune
maladie de carré bleu et le bar mais en
raquettes assume pas et monsieur georges
aurait peut-être une différence c'est
possible nous aurions plus de mal à nous
comprendre
je voulais simplement dire que c'est
vrai qu'il ya en france moins de foyers
fiscaux qui payent l'impôt sur le revenu
mais ce qu'on oublie toujours de dire
c'est qu'il ya un deuxième impôt sur le
revenu en france dont personne ne parle
tout simplement parce qu'il est prélevé
à la source nous ne sortons pas de notre
poche c'est notre employeur qui le
prennent à eve sur notre salaire
ce sont les cotisations sociales et
lorsqu on fait l'addition de l'impôt sur
le revenu et de sept autres impôts
directs que sont les cotisations
sociales
on se rend compte que les français non
seulement ne sont pas moins imposés que
les autres et en particulier pas les
français modestes mais qui sont même
beaucoup plus imposés que les autres il
faut vraiment se sortir cette idée de la
tête
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse en france
se lancer dans une grande politique
d'alourdissement et de généralisation de
l'impôt sur le revenu c'est une fausse
idée
ou alors il faudrait changer
complètement le feu le système de
financement de la sécurité sociale
vous savez qu'en grande bretagne il ya
plus de gens qui payent l'impôt sur le
revenu mais le système de santé est
financé par l'impôt parce qu'il est
nationalisée alors je veux pas rentrer
dans un débat très technique mais je
prends quand même qu'il faut bien
remettre les choses en ordre
l'inde l'une des grandes difficultés
souvent cité en ce qui concerne
l'harmonisation européenne c'est le
problème de la tva avec des taux qui
sont qui dépasse en france largement
ceux qui sont ailleurs et qu une très
grande variété
l'ancien ministre du budget que vous
êtes a certainement chiffrer ce que
coûterait à la france
l'harmonisation souhaitable de la tva
donc nous l'avons chiffré
alain madelin pourrait monsieur me
souffler le chiffre je crois que c'est
120 milliards
enfin cela dépend exactement du
calendrier compris fixes ou des
objectifs que l'on se fixe
je crois que c'est à notre portée je
voudrais quand même rappeler qu'entre
1986 et 1988
nous avons baissé les impôts de 70
milliards et par conséquent quatre ans
nous aurions pu les baisser je fais une
règle de trois peut-être un petit peu
sommaire mais de 100 à 150 milliards
simplement nous avons perdu une année
c'est quand même extraordinaire lorsque
monsieur charasse m'a succédé au
ministère du budget en 1988 il a trouvé
les caisses pleines au delà de tout ce
qu'on pouvait attendre
et au lieu d'utiliser cet argent pour
baisser les impôts dans à fait autre
chose ça va nous rendre beaucoup plus
difficile l'harmonisation fiscale de
1993 il va falloir s'y mettre à bride
abattue dans les trois ans qui viennent
ça va être intéressant de voir comment
les gouvernements le fait pour le budget
de 90 ça nous promet une discussion
budgétaire un peu sportive ses 120
milliards selon vous ils doivent être
gagner non pas par des recettes
supplémentaires sur d'autres postes mais
mais par moins de dépenses oui
moins de dépenses de l'état absolument
et dans tous les domaines oui vous savez
les économies ça se fait partout
la défense aussi nous avons voté une loi
de programmation il faut l'appliquer
il faut l'appliquer ou est ce qu'on peut
pour que la défense participe comme tout
le monde sait les fleuves
il faut les régates également nous avons
été capables de baisser les dépenses
veut faire des économies et de baisser
les impôts tout en faisant une loi de
programmation
il ya une formule de certaines des amis
de l'udf que j'aime beaucoup et qui
consiste à dire c'est 120 milliards on
nous dit que ce sont des économies mais
c'est pas de l'argent perdu
c'est pas de l'argent qui disparaît en
fumée c'est de l'argent qui reste dans
les caisses de la france il est plus
dans les caisses de l'état mais il est
dans les caisses de la france et je
crois que pour notre dynamisme
économique c'est une bonne chose
je voulais revenir un tout petit instant
aussi sur les sur les verts sur
l'écologie vous disiez tout à l'heure il
faut pas se laisser intoxiquer
alors je voudrais j'ai dit par les
puissances du mal et de missions
économiques
mais je voulais prendre ce terme
d'intoxiquer sur sur deux points précis
l'un ou sur lequel les années sans une
écologie de trait sont très sensibles
c'est l'industrie nucléaire
l'énergie nucléaire est ce qu'il y a eu
dans le passé ses années récentes une
intoxication des gouvernements
successifs par par exemple par l'edf
je crois que notre programme
électronucléaire a été fait dans des
conditions de sécurité maximum que c'est
un des grands atouts de la france aux
journées n'y a pas citées ou n'aurions
pas l'indépendance nous n'aurions pas
l'indépendance énergétique que nous
avons la france ne pourrait pas
compenser certains autres de ses
handicaps
nous avons très peu de matière première
en france si nous n'avions pas fait ce
programme je crois que le président
pompidou lorsqu'il a lancé ça enfin
c'est le cas des terrains terrain sur
lequel vous ne vivez pas les écologistes
je ne peux pas dire que je suis d'accord
surtout bien entendu sans ça je serai
moi même tout vert déjà oui non mais
parce que je veux tout le monde vers 17
ans 1 m de vannes hier il faisait
remarquer là le point qui fait remarquer
récemment tout le monde vers 10 ans
comment est ce que vous vous êtes vous
élus parisiens est ce que vous vous
n'êtes pas un peu dans les années
passent et laisser intoxiquer par des
automobilistes est ce qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup sacrifié paris à la bagnole
comme disait le président pompidou
justement j'étais à londres la semaine
dernière j'ai pris ma voiture dans un
taxi plus exactement pour aller du
centre de londres à l'aéroport
d'heathrow
j'ai mis deux heures et demie le
problème de l'embouteillage des grandes
villes est un problème général on
retrouve partout dans le monde et
partout en france
aller à toulouse aller à marseille vous
verrez que le problème n'est pas
spécifiquement parisien alors je ne dis
pas ça pour éluder la question il faut
une politique et moi j'en suis
personnellement partisan je suis pas
tout à fait c'est vrai suivi par tous
mes amis sur ce point moi je suis
partisan d'une politique plus ferme en
matière de circulation automobile je
veux dire mars suivie par le maire
jacques chirac dit il faut une politique
plus ferme
mais avant d'appliquer cette fermeté ou
en même temps qu'on applique cette
fermeté il faut donner des moyens de
substitution c'est à dire qu'on doit pas
être la proposition de cire joxe et le
succès qu'on sait à ces élections
municipales qui consisterait à dire pour
régler le problème de la circulation
interdisons les automobiles c'est quand
même d'une très grande rusticité et
comme opposition qui programment
sursauter reprennent après l'appel est
ce que nous disons nous c'est développer
les moyens de substitution
les transports en commun et nous avons
de grands projets je ne vais pas ici
refaire la campagne des municipales à
paris pour les cinq ou six prochaines
années
créons des parcs de stationnement et à
partir de ce moment là nous pouvons
avoir une politique plus stricte du
répressif d'une certaine manière contre
le stationnement sauvage moi je suis
profondément choquée je ne vous le cache
pas parle indiscipline et là vous allez
me dire que les élections municipales
sont passées que j'ai maintenant le
courage de le dire je les dis avant par
la discipline de beaucoup
d'automobilistes parisien qui
stationnent en double en triple file et
qui empoisonnent la vie des gens
l'écologie c'est aussi le respect
d'autrui vous vous prendriez le riasq r
vous feriez de voir combien nous en bas
si elle n'existait pas laissez moi vous
dire je ne sais pas où on en sort et
dans paris vous prendriez le risque qu'a
pris quelqu'un d'autre à votre place il
ya quelques temps de dire je
il faut plus jamais faire ôter les
contraventions il faut que les élus il
faut que les élus refusent de faire
coter les contraventions de leurs
électeurs je crois que j'ai commencé il
ya cinq six mois à répondre à ceux qui
me intervenez auprès de moi en disant
que je ne pouvais plus rien faire sur ce
point une dernière question puisqu'on en
est à paris certaines certains mauvais
esprits présente le la grande fête du
centenaire le taux réel bon comme une
contre ce qui est là le sait bien
là je me vois qu'ils manifestent j'ai
toujours refusé de faire sauter ces
contraventions là le centenaire de la
tour eiffel organisée par la mairie de
paris
est ce que c'est une anti bicentenaire
de la révolution organisé par l'état moi
j'ai pas l'esprit mal tourné c'est une
fête c'est une fête pour la tour eiffel
qui a été construite pour le premier
centenaire
j'espère que tout le monde s'y associera
essai est organisé en commun avec la
mission du bicentenaire nous avons eu
des conversations avec les missions du
bicentenaire bien sûr s'il ya bien un
sujet dans lequel on va pas se faire la
guéguerre c'est celui-là quand c'est pas
notre état d'esprit en douceur on ne
sait jamais vraiment nous ne sommes pas
mesquins bien merci albert rester avec
nous jean-louis le scène quatre
dernières questions oui en tant que
futurs membres de la communauté
européenne combien de langues
européennes parlez vous ne serait-il pas
temps de réformer l'apprentissage des
langues dans notre pays
hélas je n'en parle qu'une qui est
l'anglais ce n'est pas assez et je crois
que les barrières linguistiques voilà le
noeud du problème si je puis dire en
europe
je suis pour ma part favorable à ce
qu'on enseigne de langues vivantes
obligatoire dans tous les pays de la
communauté et le plus tôt possible
donc si on peut commencer dans le
primaire il faut commencer dans le
primaire il ya quelques initiatives en
ce sens il faudra les généraliser vous
avez déclaré il ya quelques mois que la
gauche française était la plus bête du
monde mac n'est vous vos propos ledit la
plus pourrie et la plus bête c'était guy
mollet en parlant de la droite aux
banques une bonne occasion de notaire ce
n'est pas douteux bien croyez vous pas
que le rajeunissement passe par le
changement à la présidence du rpr je
crois que le changement il est en route
de par la volonté de jacques chirac qui
te nomme jeunes permettez moi de le
faire remarquer et qui est entouré à la
fois de jeunes de gens d'expérience je
te suis très optimiste sur la capacité
du rpr à assumer se renouvelle
non nous en donnant l'exemple tous les
jours depuis sept ou huit mois
maintenant
ah ça c'est une question qui sera posée
à ceux qui parlent des jeunes à tout
moment on a l'impression que
actuellement on commence à être vieux et
71 ans oui vous savez sous l'antiquité
en été où enis comme on disait il reste
quelques bribes de latin jusqu'à 40 ans
alors nous sommes déjà sur la pente
déclinante tous les contestataires et
cadrages nerfs dernière question pas une
bonne querelles et c'est pas un bon
débat il ya des jeunes vieux et des
vieux jeunes il ya des jeunes qui sont
vieux dans leur tête des vingt ans et
puis il ya des gens qui à 60 ans sont
encore extraordinairement créatif et
très vert oui dernière question il y à
une émission qui suit celle ci sur le
dopage
les hommes politiques comme les sportifs
ont une vie très active
est-ce que vous ne vous devez jamais en
fait à 1000 cortisone et serrar est ce
que vous pouvez l'affirmé solennellement
ça je le jure avec la plus totale
détermination je vais vous faire une
confidence moi qui n'aime pas beaucoup
parler de moi j'avais comment je me suis
préparé à cette émission
eh bien j'ai tout simplement fait la
sieste de trois heures à 4 heures cet
après midi c'est mon seul dopage bien eh
bien on va mesurer maintenant le
résultat de cette sieste c'est l'heure
du verdict de la sofres avec avec jérôme
jaffré directeur des études politiques
de la sofres pour la première heure de
vérité de monsieur alain juppé qui était
très attendu en ces temps agités de
l'opposition nous avons mesuré sa
capacité de persuasion la capacité de
rénovation du rpr au sein de
l'opposition et l'évolution de son image
en cours d'émission bien entendu alors
sur la capacité de persuasion de
monsieur juppé nous avons bien entendu
tenu compte de ce qui a été abordé en
cours d'émission et en particulier de la
place importante compte tenu des thèmes
hors de la politique traditionnelle
comme le problème de l'environnement où
l'aide que la france peut apporter au
liban et puis un thème politique enfin
qui ait le soutien apporté à valéry
giscard d'estaing sur ces trois thèmes
je pense que les graphiques vont
apparaître
monsieur alain juppé s'est montré
convaincant en majorité aux yeux des
téléspectateurs
le premier point le meilleur résultat
c'est sur la défense la sincérité ne se
louper sur la défense de
l'environnement qui a manifestement
frappé les téléspectateurs et
l'échantillon de la sofres sur l'intérêt
et la vigueur avec laquelle il a parlé
de ce thème 59% de convaincu 27%
seulement deux n'ont convaincu sur ce
que la france peut faire pour aider
liban là le résultat est plus fait mais
évidemment le problème est très
compliqué 46% de convaincant 33 % de non
convaincant et enfin sur le thème
politique le soutien à valéry giscard
d'estaing 50% de convaincant 34 % de non
convaincant là aussi donc un sentiment
plutôt majorité deuxième question nous
l'avons posée avant le début de
l'émission nous l'avons posée dans les
dernières minutes
est ce que les dirigeants actuels du rpr
jacques chirac alain juppé peuvent mener
à bien la rénovation de l'opposition
questions posées donc en début
d'émission dans les premières minutes et
qui la faisait apparaître un handicap
très fort sur le thème de la rénovation
25 % seulement de réponses positives 53
% de réponses négatives en fin
d'émission je dirais que monsieur juppé
a pratiquement réussi à remonter le
handicap puisque nous sommes à 38 % de
réponses positives 42 % de réponses
négatives
au fond les sondages montrent que les
thèmes rénovateurs sont des thèmes
populaires dans l'opinion ce qui
apparaît à travers l'émission de ce soir
c'est qu'il est possible à ce que des
dirigeants qu'ils n'apparaissent pas
qu'ils sont pas classés parmi les
rénovateurs puisse reprendre à leur
compte c'est m troisième question bien
sûr c'est une autre question
traditionnelle l'image de monsieur juppé
pour cette première heure de vérité
est-ce qu'on a une bonne opinion de lui
poser en début d'émission est posée en
fin d'émission début d'émission là aussi
très partagés probablement la situation
actuelle de l'opposition créer un petit
peu un clivage plus accentuée 43% de
bonnes opinions
36 % de mauvaises fins d'émission 56% de
bonnes 13 points de gagner donc un gain
sensible 31 % de mauvaises
et là évidemment ce qui est intéressant
c'est des éléments de comparaison
monsieur juppé fait mieux que son
prédécesseur jacques toubon secrétaire
général du rpr quand il était venu à
l'heure de vérité il avait obtenu 51% de
bonnes opinions il fait même mieux que
charles pasqua qui a fait 50% de bonnes
opinions en janvier et situe juste est
ce que c'est un respect pour un ancien
à cet égard il situe juste en dessous de
françois léotard qui avait obtenu 57% de
bonnes opinions début février
c'est donc un résultat qui situe la
position de monsieur juppé parmi les
autres leaders jeunes leaders de
l'opposition bien un commentaire je
pense à ceux qui restent à convaincre
bien sûr bien eh bien c'était donc
l'heure de vérité de monsieur alain
juppé prochain rendez vous le lundi 1er
mai avec monsieur philippe herzog qui
conduira la liste du parti communiste
aux élections européennes n'oubliez pas
d'envoyer vos messages par minitel 36 15
codes à 2 bonsoir merci
[Musique]